saw Hill Bloom was a former investment
banker managing over two and a half
billion dollars in his twenties we went
from half a billion dollars to managing
three and a half billion dollars then he
decided to quit being bored having those
periods of silence and quiet time is
when you figure out what those
non-linear opportunities are I follow
his Twitter and that's where I get most
of my information from and I have to say
he is a genius when it comes to All
Things business personal finance and
investing strategies that we gotta just
dig deeper so if you guys enjoy episodes
like this make sure to subscribe because
we have episodes coming out every single
Sunday here on the iced coffee hour
thank you so much and with that said
thank you so much dreamyard for
sponsoring this episode stream yard is a
live streaming platform that allows you
to create high quality content with just
the click of a button all you need is a
camera and an internet connection to be
able to stream content right from your
browser one of my favorite things about
stream yard is the fact that you can
multi-stream which means that you can be
live on YouTube Facebook LinkedIn and
more all at the same time through the
platform basically expanding your reach
for free I also really enjoy that stream
yard gives you really cool analytics
tools so that you could analyze the
success of every single live stream that
you do streamyard is the best way to
start creating content without having to
spend any money I mean you guys see the
studio here it was wildly expensive it
hurt our pockets very much but you can
get started creating high quality
content on stream yard for free today
seriously guys stream yard is fantastic
if you want to live stream at all they
make it so easy to do and if you're
interested in doing that we do have a
link Down Below in the description where
you could get started today for free
once again guys the link is down below
in the description it also helps support
the podcast so it mean a lot to us thank
you so much stream yard and back to the
podcast why do you carry a notebook
everywhere I write a lot man you know
this this is like my my thing I mean you
you guys have your craftsmanship around
video and everything you do for me
writing is my thing and so I just try to
like log interesting experiences ideas
struggles
Etc that I'm having during the course of
the day and I end up going back and
looking at the notebook I don't know
maybe like five percent of the time but
something about the actual writing
process of it it like just starts to
register Idea Idea percolation in my
mind it's like I think James Clear said
it at one point anything that you end up
writing like content you create is
Downstream from something you consume
and so for me things I consume sometimes
it's things I'm reading or listening to
or whatever but a lot of times it's just
things that I'm thinking on a daily
basis and if I don't write those things
down they never end up having the like
time to kind of seep in my mind sure and
work together so the writing is big how
do you know it's worth it to write down
and what's not like if you're like I'm
hungry I'm thinking of Big Mac right now
I try to I mean I try not to be
judgmental about it you know it's like
some I'm sure if you went back and
looked in the pages of this there would
be some garbage like that that's just
sitting around like you know I'm sitting
on a plane actually today I'm sitting on
a plane and the guy in front of me
reclined his seat and I was like in
recliners man these like airplane
reasons
two inches dude this is the most
ridiculous thing
well this is like my favorite Twitter
debate by the way is like the whole
recline you know there have been a few
funny to Twitter debates that have come
up like I don't know do you know Cody
Sanchez yes so Cody had the one recently
that she set off about picking people up
from the airport did you see this so
Cody tweeted like I will never be
participating in this trend about it was
like a girl had said she was going to
pick up a friend at the airport
and Cody was like I'm never doing that
if you're my real friend you'll just get
an Uber like I shouldn't have to be
called to pick pick up your friend at
airport like if you're an adult and it
set off the most insane like viral angry
discourse about whether or not you
should ask your friends to pick you up
from the airport it's funny
each other out
unfortunately yes
it's a normal house well very
responsible respectful men but uh albeit
well there's this
so you could be responsible and
respectful in a frat by the way yeah we
do have a ping pong room too okay yeah
with industrial okay okay but anyways uh
we have this debate within us I'm the
only person that airs on the side of I
don't think it's worth it to go pick
someone up from the airport and drop
them off because I I just time his money
baby I would Uber I have no problem
ubering uh especially and then but of
course I'm I get asked to pick people up
so I'm like okay if I get asked I may as
well ask them back make it more
transactional yeah okay so Airport
pickup thing exactly I think it just
makes more sense especially like since
you'd be wasting their time and like
then you have to make sure you get the
timing right yeah when you get off the
plane and like
what do you think uh I don't think it's
really worth it but if you care about a
person and I think it's a good gesture
yeah like if it was my you know if it
was a woman that I was hoping to build a
relationship with I'm going and picking
them up but I would not I mean I would
find it weird I suppose if a friend of
mine hit me up that was like coming to
town and was like hey can you pick me up
from the airport it's one thing if I
offer yeah and I'm like totally cool you
know like if a friend's coming that I
haven't seen in a really long time I
might be like hey you can swing by the
airport if I don't have anything going
on but for someone to ask you it's sort
of like dude just get a cab like you're
an adult just get get an Uber Graham but
every single time we land he's always
like Jack hit up one of your friends to
come pick us up every like it happens it
makes me Google man he's running a
business
split an Uber so we could we could split
new it's not bad it's like 20 bucks each
but here's the thing gram are you just
super Frugal yes uh yeah well if someone
is at the house they're not doing
anything are you known for your
frugality is this part of your brand
okay yeah okay but my point being if if
but if they're not doing anything anyway
then I think it makes sense okay you
know all right if they want it obviously
if they say no I'm not going to be like
every text grand for a ride back from
the airport
point being though that was one like
wild Twitter you know argument that went
off the one before that was airplane
seat reclining and whether it's like
immoral and whether you're a terrible
person if you recline you see it on an
airplane and I had honestly never known
that that was a thing until I saw that
people were popping off about it I had
talked about like you know people that
don't put their grocery carts away uh in
shop you know in shopping centers things
like that whatever but people related it
then to this airport airplane seat
recline and I had no idea that that was
a thing I was like baffled that people
get that angry about it and then I sat
on an airplane and I like started
observing and watching people do this
and it is [__] annoying man it
doesn't bother me if someone reclines
their seat in front of me it does not it
doesn't bother you it bugs me is when
they do it really quick fast dude the
dive bombers man the Kamikaze
your laptop's right there someone jams
it down into your lap really slowly I
kind of look behind yeah
I just give them notice yeah well what
if you have a drink on there or your
laptop it gets jammed up but it's just
like does the two inches of Recon really
make your experience that much more
comfortable because you're basically
saying that like my two inches of
recline is worth more to me than your
miserable experience on this flight but
they could then reclined behind you and
get that two inches back it just sets
off a chain reaction and pissing people
off the entire point right and then the
very back seat by the way does not
require doesn't recline yeah yeah so
they're stuck and you're next to the
bathroom too so you get both yeah you
come both ways anyway yeah well that is
interesting all the more reason to fly
first classroom do you fly first class
yeah
every time yeah
yeah why uh it makes my experience so so
much better I like can get things done
and get the refresh Southwest first
class Southwest doesn't have first class
but the priorities no like I'll pay for
I'll pay for first class on flight like
you know fun too yeah like if I'm doing
cross-country like JetBlue mint is
actually pretty reasonably priced for
what it is but you get a full you know
experience in space I like my whole life
I never did that obviously I have the
means fortunately to be able to now and
for me I get like if I'm doing a one day
trip like I'm here for a day I want to
be able to do a bunch of writing on the
flight because otherwise I'm losing an
entire day of writing on the you know
eight hours ten hours of flying me doing
that an economy with some you know jerk
reclining into me while I'm doing that
it's basically gonna be impossible and
so for me I'm like the calculation of me
just spending the money on doing it
versus the time that I would be losing
on the writing it's actually probably
worth it sometimes it's not like flying
first class to you know India on
Emirates where you're playing like
paying a whole lot to go yeah right and
if you're running it through your
business it's like you know 50 off when
you take off the taxes and stuff so you
can figure out a way to justify it but
it's expensive nonetheless
um but yeah I do now in order to fly
first class you must be doing pretty
well for yourself right that's why
you're here because you've built up some
incredible businesses how exactly did
you get to where you are today could you
give us a little synopsis yeah
um so look I mean I started my uh I
started my career in like a pretty
mainstream track so I went to Stanford I
played baseball in Stanford um I thought
I was going to play professionally I had
like these big hopes and dreams like
most kids when they go and uh you know
going to Collegiate Athletics everyone
tells you the whole thing of like 99 of
you know NCAA athletes will never do
this professionally but you never
believe that you always think you're
going to be the one
um I got hurt my last year and so that
kind of derailed whatever aspirations I
had had to figure out what I was doing
next I ended up stumbling into a role at
a private Equity Fund that was just
getting started in the Bay Area in 2014
and I took it over a job at McKinsey in
New York and from like you know Indian
mother right so like name brand things
are big in Indian culture and so the
idea of me going to some like no-name
private Equity Fund that she you know
she didn't even know what private Equity
was neither did I over McKinsey like my
mom I don't know to this day I think
she's like what the [__] were you
thinking that's crazy the whole idea of
that I mean she still wants me to go to
medical school like she still asked
today yeah I mean she's like are you
sure you don't want to be a doctor I'm
like Mom yeah it's kind of far like I
don't think I can do this
um so anyway I took this job didn't
really know what I was getting into but
I happened to be one of the first I
don't know 10 employees at this private
Equity Fund that was managing a half a
billion dollars at the time
um over the course of seven years that I
stayed there full time we went from half
a billion dollars to managing three and
a half billion dollars I was co-leading
all consumer investing for the fund
sitting on a bunch of boards had an
amazing experience did the like Finance
grind right what was that like because I
hear it's it's a ton of hours yeah like
16 hours a day you're sleeping under
your desk yeah I didn't do the sleeping
under my desk unfortunately
um I did yeah I did a couple
all-nighters in the office but never
slept there
um but yeah I mean it's look it's part
of the learning experience it's like
anything like when you're diving into it
I'm sure you guys have done this with
what you're building your careers around
it's like if you want to learn a lot you
have to work hard I'm not one of these
people that'll come out and say oh yeah
working hard is overrated it's you know
just work smart and that's what matters
like my big belief frankly is did you
play video games when you're a kid using
video game analogy okay so there are
these games when you're a kid where like
you start on a map and the whole map is
black you can't say anything and you're
in the one spot you can see where you
are and as you start exploring around it
lights the map up like you went and you
kind of uncovered the different regions
and then you can kind of see the whole
map and you see where all the resources
are and you know where you should be
building and doing all your you know
building your army whatever I think that
that same thing applies to your career
where like when you start you just are
in one little spot that's where you
started everything else is black out
there and by working hard and by saying
yes to things early on and taking on
these different opportunities you like
spread light around the map and then you
can see everything and you can decide
like where do I want to deploy my effort
and get leverage out of it like where is
the gold that I can go deeper down and
figure out but without that first part
you're just going to try to go deep in
an area you have no idea what's there it
can be a total show and so like I'm a
big big believer that early on that hard
work just pays off in a big big way Jack
what are you doing I'm getting engaged
ma'am shouldn't you be eating something
with more protein than cereal oh silly
program this ain't just any old cereal
It's Magic spoon do you just carry that
with you everywhere magic spoon is
serial reinvented not only is it
delicious but it's also wholesome and
satiating all right let me try that
foreign
variety pack comes in
four different flavors again you carry
this all with you everywhere so one we
have peanut butter then we have frosted
and we also have oh this looks pretty
good cocoa wait a second Jack I'm
looking at this one serving is only 140
calories 13 grams of protein and only
four grams of carbs magic spoon is
perfect for those who are carb conscious
and trying to live a low carb lifestyle
so click the link in the description to
try out the variety pack Jack stop that
I can't help it it is good isn't it
anyway so click the link below to try a
variety pack today just make sure to use
the promo code ich to get five dollars
off of any order or you could just go to
magicspoon.com ich and Magic spoon is so
confident in their product they're
backed by a 100 happiness guarantee so
if you're not fully satisfied they'll
give you a full refund again click the
link Down Below in the description or
scan this QR code that's appearing on
the screen right now and use code ich to
get five dollars off and now with that
said let's get back to the podcast what
would you be doing in those days though
like what would that involve it depended
on what level you are so analysts
um the hours are largely like you know
cranking through analysis it's like
modeling right like you're building
Financial models in private Equity it's
like you know you're doing leverage
buyouts so you're taking on debt to buy
companies and so the whole model there
is you're like looking at the cash flows
of the business and seeing if it can
service the debt that you're going to
put on the business and pressure testing
it in a variety of scenarios and that
always just takes a whole bunch of time
and energy and eventually it probably
should be done by AI like those models
should probably be getting automated but
it wasn't at the time and so it's very
manual and you're having to crank
through it is this like a formula or
some sort of algorithm that you put in
all the data in and it like I mean it's
like a multi-tab spreadsheet it's like a
three statement financial model so
you're looking at a financial model and
you have to take the numbers from the
company the problem if you're investing
in a sophisticated public company and
you're gonna go buy a public company
like blackstone's a big private Equity
Fund they're gonna go buy some big
public company and take it private that
company has tons of like really clean
nice beautiful financial statements that
they can take and very easily drop into
a model and it's super easy to kind of
have a template for the companies we
were investing in like Middle Market a
lot of family-owned businesses you're
talking about like poorly kept
QuickBooks financials for the last
several years so you can't just like
grab numbers out of a spreadsheet and
put them into your spreadsheet it's not
that easy like that you know someone's
going to be running their like country
club membership through the financials
and you need to figure out should that
stay should that go like there's all
these things that you need to be asking
questions about that end up taking a lot
of time because you're having to kind of
like dig through the weeds of these
businesses so what types of businesses
were you buy like would you just find
like some hat store down the street and
they're like doing all right but you're
gonna do it better and you buy it I mean
these had to be big because we were
investing
um you know we were investing in 10 to
like 50 million ebitda businesses so
they were doing 100 plus million of
Revenue so I mean we looked at
everything like I spent some time in
Oilfield Services in like Midland Texas
you know going down there and like going
and looking at pump jack businesses like
those things that are kind of how would
you know what you're looking at like why
would they send you down there I mean
you go these private Equity Funds are
very good about like finding an operator
who has been there done that with that
industry and then pair them with
horsepower I.E the analyst who can like
crank through this okay so that person
is like your field guide you go down and
they're the one telling you like this is
interesting or not and then if it is yes
interesting and we're gonna spend time
on it pass it over to like cogs in the
machine who are going to do the actual
grunt work to figure out how to make the
numbers work to do a deal
um and that's the I mean it's a model
that has worked for the private Equity
industry for a long time
um but man it's It's a Grind when you're
early in your career is there ever any
pressure that like you were worried
about being wrong on some of that so
like how many people review that before
it goes up to the point of actually
purchasing something yeah I mean I think
that happens uh and you hear funny
stories of it now and then like there's
some model that's wrong and someone
loses 80 million dollars or there's like
a wire that gets sent that's wrong the
scariest thing which is a funny thing
that no one talks about or writes about
are these things called funds flow so
when a deal gets done the last step of
the deal getting done is like wires need
to get sent to all the different people
and so in one of these companies like
you know there's not just one owner of
the company there's like a cap table
that has tons of different shareholders
and they own different percentages and
they get you know different thresholds
where they get paid out different
amounts there's all the like banks that
lend money to all these different wires
and so when you're looking at a deal
there's this document called a funds
flow that usually the analyst manages
that literally has all of the different
wires that have to get sent to all the
different places the exact amounts that
have to get sent and the wiring details
of all the different people that are
having the wires sent where they're
coming from where they're going one
letter being off in one of those
documents sends like tens of millions of
dollars to the wrong freaking place and
so there was always this joke of like oh
yeah did you add in that you know that
one that sends it to the Cayman Islands
bank account for me or whatever like you
know send off like 250k no one will know
like in this you know a billion dollars
is Flowing maybe no one will notice and
it was always like this hilarious thing
because literally there's some analyst
that's managing the I mean I did one
deal where I was the only one that knew
where like two billion dollars of funds
were flowing one morning like we said
yes all the wires get sent and two
billion dollars are falling and
everyone's assuming that I'm right that
like this thing actually works yeah
manually into an Excel spreadsheet and
by the way Excel if if something has a
leading like zero in an Excel document
it automatically eliminates it so if you
don't put like a apostrophe before the
zero you can actually miss a zero and so
like there are actually things that can
happen that can like screw up the entire
deal uh I always just thought that was
so so funny because you would hear
stories every now and then I'm like
someone screwing up and you're like oh
that's the nightmare like you get fired
for something like that that's crazy had
that ever happened that you're a firm
never at our firm but you'd hear I mean
like you'd hear about it like in you
know the Grapevine of stuff like oh some
deal got had to get like redone at the
last second because of why fire went to
the wrong place just because someone got
the wrong amount or like whatever common
in real estate but for wire fraud used
to be a huge thing like what would
happen so like between 2012 and 2016
wire fraud was beginning to ramp up and
what they would do they'd usually crack
into like an escrow accounts email
address find the buyer but then send
them fake wiring instructions they look
legitimate like the same thing just with
the numbers changed around so the buyer
would see this and think oh I'm safe to
wire my money here at closing they'd
have no idea and so they wire the money
there and then escrow calls a day later
we never got your wire well I sent it we
never received it who did you send it to
I sent it to this that's not our bank
account and so I've seen instances
happen before of people wiring millions
of dollars to the wrong place to
scammers and thankfully in every
scenario that I've like seen I've never
been a party to it but like just I've
heard of these things the FBI and the
police get involved and they're usually
able to get it back if they catch it
within like 24 48 hours they could trace
it back and send it yeah but they're
like hours from someone like just
getting a money order yeah and then like
leaving the country with with millions
of dollars the other one I always found
funny was ransomware attacks we used to
get ransomware attacked a lot like uh
you know this became a big thing
especially with Middle Market companies
the type of companies we had because
sophisticated public companies have
these like incredible cyber security
infrastructure that they've paid for
tons of money a random like Middle
Market company you know somewhere in the
country doesn't have all the money to
spend on cyber security infrastructure
and so you would get hacked and
basically these attackers would come in
it would be a ransomware attack which
locks all of your access to data
and it's encrypted and so the only way
you can unencrypt it is with a key that
they're going to give you and their
whole thing was like you can't do
business like we had a business that was
doing 250 million in one year completely
shut down like could not sell buy do
anything until we got this key to unlock
all of our data and their whole thing is
like okay if you pass five million
dollars in Bitcoin we'll give you the
key otherwise you don't get it back and
you're not allowed to do business and it
became this like efficient market almost
where we would just pay and you had to
get insurance that would cover the
payment and no like the insurance
company would negotiate with the hackers
yeah and it was like an efficient market
because they the hacker knew that they
actually had to deliver the key because
otherwise the next time they did it
people would just say no I'm not paying
you I know you're not going to deliver
the key and so like this one company it
happened to us and they they asked for
five and we negotiated it down to a
million and we sent them a million
dollars a Bitcoin and then they unlocked
our data and like two days later we were
had back access but that was happening
the guys do they know where they are
yeah there was like North Korean Rings
Russian rings it was like a big big I
mean and a lot of people thought it was
State sanctioned stuff that was
happening but there was like the Wall
Street Journal did a big expose on it it
was fascinating actually seeing it
happen in real time because you're like
you know this random this was like you
know a random company that had to like
acquire and then send Bitcoin to these
hackers in order to get access how much
would Insurance be on something like
that um I actually don't know what the
premiums were yeah they were ramping up
a lot oh yeah yeah they were ramping up
especially as become became more
prevalent right and the insurance
premiums were all reliant on what your
infrastructure actually is and so for
middle you know if you had great cyber
security infrastructure and Tech
infrastructure it was cheaper but for
most of these companies it wasn't great
and so you were paying a lot yeah I mean
it was probably fifty thousand dollars
plus and in cyber insurance premiums
okay so when you were working at this
company can you say what you were
earning throughout the time yeah I mean
I was making like by the time I was a
vice president which was like you know
six seven years in you're making like
seven figures of all in compensation
you know carry in the funds your cash
comp is like you know mid to high six
figures and then you have carried
interest so Equity profit share in the
funds it's your late 20s at that time
yeah so I was a 27 when I became a vice
president
um how did you get to vice president of
2016. I mean the holy vice president
thing is hilarious in finance because
it's like okay yeah I'm a vice president
like it's a meme now because like
literally it's a bunch of 27 year old
kids that are like I'm a vice president
and like you know I'm sitting on my
first board because when you become a
vice president that's when you can sit
on boards usually sure
um because it sounds official enough but
you're like a 27 year old kid what are
you doing sitting on a board of a
company I still thought it was
ridiculous
um but yeah I became so I did two years
as an analyst two years as an associate
and then like a year as a senior
associate and then became a vice
president and you know we were a small
firm so like if you were doing well and
the funds were growing and we were
raising bigger funds funds were
performing well you kind of got on an
accelerated track
um and we I mean I wouldn't even say we
were like paying in the like top 10 like
private Equity is a very very lucrative
track for kids out of school because
right away you're making north of you
know 150 up to 200 maybe and you're like
analyst years associate years and then
by the time you're a VP you're making at
least you know 500k of cash comp plus
you have interest you know profit
sharing the funds how many years does it
usually take to become an associate um
Associates after two years as an analyst
or two years in banking or Consulting
that's like the first thing when you
come into it and like the you know the
reason that people go they go into
banking for two years they go to like
Goldman Sachs and go to Investment Bank
for two years and they put up with 100
hour work weeks and the misery of it
it's because they're hoping to get this
like lucrative private Equity or hedge
fund gig as soon as they come out of
that a lot of them now are recruiting
you're locking in your private Equity or
hedge fund job before starting your
banking job so you start your banking
job knowing that you're leaving and that
you're going to be going to this other
place in two years why do they set it up
like that are they that hungry for
people to work with them or how does
they're basically the private Equity
Funds and hedge funds are basically
Outsourcing their training to the banks
and consulting firms and the banks and
consulting firms the banks in particular
don't really care because they're happy
to get two years of like crazy hard work
from some young smart kid and then have
them leave and the reality for the banks
is like they only need one out of every
like 10 you know good analysts to rise
up and become a partner because they
don't have a room they can't have 100
Partners sitting at the top they need a
bunch of people called and so they're
happy to have like a lineage that goes
to these great firms it improves their
brand it's kind of like a symbiotic
relationship but it's crazy I mean
you're making a lot of money at a young
age working really hard your hourly rate
sucks your hourly rate really sucks but
you sound you know the status of it
feels good you're like you know you're
flying first class for work like it
feels good wow so how do you justify
quitting that then
before we go to that I'm curious how you
leveled up so fast
um what do you what do you feel set
yourself apart
yeah I mean look I part of it is a track
like you get on the track by doing well
your first you know year year and a half
I mean honestly first impressions are
everything like you do well your first
like three months and people like you
and you say yes to everything and you're
you know setting the standard that you
work really hard and that you're uh you
know a good frankly team member and that
you're not weird like that they can
bring you to a meeting and you're not
going to be weird I played baseball my
whole life I'd been in locker rooms
all these Middle Market businesses are
run by a bunch of people that like to
talk about sports so like I could go to
a meeting and shoot the hit with some
guys that like baseball and talk to them
about my glory years and they loved that
and so like being able to be normal so
it helped a lot what would be weird
though if they ask about like a baseball
and you're like I don't know what that
is honestly no I mean honestly the
weirdest you know I don't know that is
weird but but the weirdest thing you can
do in a meeting in my opinion is uh
present yourself as like better than
them in some way and this was a big big
risk in private equity and in the
finance World in general is because you
know like I I went to Stanford right
like we were hiring kids that went to
Princeton Stanford Harvard like all
these like Elite pedigreed kids and if
you took one of them to a meeting in uh
you know middle of Kansas and into a
guy's company who's running you know a
playset business that's doing 300
million of Revenue 50 million of eBay
the guy has an airplane hangar in his
back but he's from Kansas he grew up
there like he hasn't you know gone to
some some fancy school but he's
unbelievably successful and you bring in
an analyst that is almost like talking
down to him in a certain way because
like they see they feel like they're so
smart that they went to school that's
really bad you can't have that be like
the type of relationship that gets set
and I saw that a bunch you'd see you
know analysts all the way up through
directors that would like give off an
air of superiority and it's like a
coastal thing that I think is just a bad
thing in general we've seen it
societally as a country
um but that that is weird and that's
really hard to accelerate if you're that
and if you're if you're crazy so what do
you do if you see that do you pull them
aside you're like hey you gotta cool it
or do you just let them do their thing
and they'll kind of fall into place it
depends who you are as the senior person
I mean we had people that would give
that feedback very directly and that was
great I I've always been big on like
give me the feedback right away because
I want to be able to improve on whatever
the thing is that's from an athlete
background like it's what I believed in
um some people didn't do that and so
then you know you'd get a year in and
you'd get your first review and it was
like Hey you're not doing so great here
and you'd wonder why because you hadn't
been given that feedback along the way
but I think you have to tell the person
right away because usually they don't
mean anything negative by it it's not
like they're trying to be condescending
or trying to give off that Vibe it's
just they've always been around like
they went to a fancy private school in
New York and then they went to Harvard
and then they you know got this fancy
private Equity job and so they've only
been around that type of culture and you
get put into a different environment you
have to learn how to adapt now I think
saying yes is so important I think
that's one of the huge quality that
people don't really pick up on what are
some of the weird requests that you've
gotten I'm sure there's got to be some
like Ops stuff it's like you know I am
going to say yes to it I mean yes man
but
um I had to go to a catfish farm in
Louisiana
um to go like see how the catfish were
going on a conveyor belt once that was
that was a pretty weird request we were
looking at investing in this catfish
farm and people wanted to see it
actually in action now like this catfish
farm was real and look I'm like real I'm
23. you know I'm like 23 24 getting out
of school I thought that was the coolest
thing in the freaking world I was like
this is amazing that I could do this I
was like down in Midland Texas uh you
know like going and driving through the
fields to go like make sure that these
like pump jacks are working it was like
an amazing experience that when you say
yes to you get to like go see all these
things my first actually my first like
month working
um you know I thought private Equity was
gonna be like sitting at a desk and
cranking out numbers on an Excel
spreadsheet and I literally was in Fargo
North Dakota uh helping one of our like
um retail uh sales people at one of the
companies we owned uh like fix uh store
signage at one of our at one of our
stores in the place like I was like
climbing up a ladder and like fixing
this store signage at the top of the
store because it was looking kind of
janky and I was just sitting there like
wow this is not what I expected my
finances to be gosh but it was fun man I
I totally agree with you on saying yes I
think especially early on saying yes to
things just kind of expands your like
surface area of luck you know you just
get exposed to new things people start
looking to you for opportunities when
they have something cool come up they
then are like oh yeah Graham said you
know was around doing that thing he did
that one thing well let me call him in
to like sit in and just listen to this
call that I'm about to do and that's
when you end up learning in a world with
rampant ads not enough content and
uncomfortable YouTuber merch two men
Brave against the standards and create
something more Community oriented more
robust and wait for it ad free
this is Jack and Graham starring in the
iced coffee hour Club linked below
that's because.com was taken
if you want an extra in-house episode
every single month if you want ad-free
uninterrupted content and early access
to every episode then the iced coffee
hour Club is for you starting at just
five dollars and completely free for the
first month you can have access to all
of that and more
iced coffee hour dot Club linked down
below seriously guys enough of the voice
man guys check it out with the link Down
Below in the description it would mean a
ton and the first month is free for a
limited time so check it out before it
expires with the link down below thank
you so much and let's get back to the
episode
now you mentioned before there are four
types of luck out there could you
explain that I thought that was so
insightful that makes a lot of sense
yeah I mean the first type is blind luck
yeah this is just like what we think of
as a luck frankly it's like a place
right time just happen to yeah things
like that it's like you know Act of God
it's like where you were born who you
were born to
um you know the second one is luck from
motion this is like hustle luck it's
kind of what we're talking about it's
like you're hustling and this is you
know you're creating Motion in an
ecosystem so where you're like literally
driving connections where people are
bumping into each other you're like
connecting people and so then all of a
sudden you're brought into stuff that
you otherwise wouldn't have been
um the third type is luck from awareness
this is like
you are so deep with knowledge in a
given area that you're able to spot luck
you see it from a mile away you're like
man I've been in this you know in the
YouTube space for so long that I can see
where the ball is going before it's
there so I can we can position ourselves
out in front of that yeah it's kind of
lucky that you were there before it but
not really because you've been doing all
the work and then the last type is luck
from uniqueness and this is kind of the
weirdest and like most esoteric type
which is just like your weird quirky
habits and quirky hobbies and quirky
loves and dislikes and all those things
lead to luck actually being attracted to
you so like you know the example that
Naval gives around this is like a
someone that's really into weird uh like
treasure diving and they're like super
into this they've been doing this for 20
years and so then there's this rare deep
sea find in the ocean and they're the
first person that everyone calls and so
it's kind of lucky that they got the
call but really it's because they were
so unique and they had this esoteric set
of interests and skills that they
actually get the luck brought to them
yeah I just think having an awareness of
those different types and how you kind
of approach things over the course of
your life is interesting because your
life starts with all blind luck you're
like where you're born who you're born
to the situations you come into that's
all blind luck you can't control that
but then as you start moving you start
building into that second type of luck
of hustling you're trying to create
motion you're trying to do things as you
start going deeper in your life and into
your career it's more luck from
awareness it's more like hey how can I
spot these opportunities that are out
there and then there's the fourth type
which is like it requires years of weird
interest experience hobby etc for that
to even ever come to you and into your
life so I've always thought that the
progression of that over the course of
your life is a really really interesting
concept
I like that how did you going back to
Jack's question now justify quitting
because making seven figures late 20s
that's really really hard to walk away
from because you could very easily
justify if I just do this another 10
years and save I'll be set yeah so this
is a this is a ninja this opens a can of
worms so I hope you're ready
so I um covid hit May or March of 2020.
um I was marching down the path to
become a partner at this fund I was
honestly like loving it I had a great
experience the group of people was
incredible I was learning a ton but in
the back of my mind I was always like is
this what I'm gonna really do the rest
of my life part of that was just because
I was never that motivated by money like
the whole industry if you're gonna be
great at private Equity if you're gonna
be the best at private Equity you have
to [__] love money like you have to
just want to make money like you know
one of the most successful private
Equity Funds in the world is led by this
guy who I don't want to say his name
because people will know him but he
during fundraising uh told this like LPS
asked him what type of people do you
want to hire and his response was I want
to hire the type of kid who he's sitting
at his grandmother's house on the couch
and he's digging between the sofas
looking for pennies that's the type of
kid I want to hire and like that's what
you have to do to be the best at private
Equity that's like a perfect microcosm
and I'm not that I like money don't get
me wrong like I I like doing nice things
I like being able to fly first class I
like being able to take care of my kids
I'm never going to care about a ten
thousand dollar bottle of wine just not
I don't have a watch like I'm wearing a
whoop band I'm not into fancy things I
like being able to have you know a nice
place take care of my family Etc but
it's just not what drives me on a daily
basis
and I started to think about that I was
like hmm you know I don't know that I'm
ever gonna be the best at this simply
because what motivates me is not what
needs to motivate me to become the best
I'm not nerding out on this stuff enough
that coincided with me discovering my
talent and love of writing
um I all of a sudden wasn't working 80
to 100 hours a week I was stuck at home
I couldn't travel we were traveling
three to four days a week for work I
couldn't do that I wasn't commuting so I
had all this time on my hands what were
they having you do in the meantime by
the way because I'm sure the equity
world was kind of dead really I mean
more I guess a month Yeah March to like
um March
April 2020 was like total chaos because
our companies some of them were just
shut down you were like right do we have
any money are we going to get PPP loans
like there was just chaos no one knew
what was going on May things kind of
settled into like there's not much new
deal activity because people don't know
what interest rates are going to be and
it's hard to get someone to loan you
money at that time and so you can't
really do a buyout so there wasn't much
New Deal activity and your companies
were kind of stable because we had
figured out that like consumers were
still spending money PPP loans were
getting you know our bad companies
through the tough time and so you were
kind of in this like weird limbo of
there wasn't a ton of new stuff and your
companies weren't in chaos and so there
wasn't a whole ton of work actually
until on the weekends I was like I have
time I don't have a social life because
you can't go out I was living in the Bay
Area so you really couldn't go out yes
when I wasn't like in Texas or in
Florida where you were fine unless
you're the governor yeah exactly then I
could go to The French Laundry and I
could go do my you know yeah exactly go
have a wedding whatever no I was not the
governor I didn't hang out with Newsome
um but look so I had time on my hands
and I was sitting around and I started
writing and this is like before Twitter
threads were the meme that they are
today
um I kind of discovered them and started
building them as like a format for
writing slightly longer form content on
the platform at the time I had like 500
Twitter followers it's like May 12th
when I posted my first thread
um and I very quickly realized there was
product Market fit to it and it was
originally around sort of personal
finance similar stuff to what you were
originally kind of doing around around
youtube personal finance you know
markets things that were happening in
the world a little bit of explainers
simplifying complex topics
and there was a big demand for that and
it started growing it started scaling by
the end of that year 2020
um it had grown to about 75 000 or so
followers on Twitter and I had spun up
um a little side business uh like an
agency business helping other people to
build their personal brand so like
startups I'd invested in things I had
done personally on the side I was
starting to help those founders with
growing their personal Brands kind of
leveraging the playbooks I'd used that
was starting to cash flow and generate
income on the side in this like little
weekend hobby by early 2021 that plus
the newsletter I just launched was
making me more money than what I was
making at my lucrative finance jobs
one year yeah not even a year I mean it
had been at that point it had been like
six months what was it what was the
percentage of the money
um what do you mean like where did the
money come from was it mostly the the
course business no no agent so agency
was the CH was the primary chunk of it
which it was like look it was it was
helping startup Founders build their
personal Brands and so it was like you
you know I could get them a Ghostwriter
if they needed one but a lot of it was
just like helping them with strategy
with the playbooks with you know the
Cadence like the things I was doing
because at the time there was like a
real Arbitrage opportunity on Twitter
too and so you could really grow quickly
by leveraging this format and leveraging
the structure and those were you know it
was like highly recurring business it
was like five thousand to ten thousand
dollars a month from someone
um you know and you would just get a set
of clients and it was pure cash flow I
didn't have costs right it was just cash
to me
um and I had a bunch of clients and so I
was like helping people on the weekends
and like I would you know help them with
all the structure stuff and it was just
generating a whole ton of cash would
those people drop off though once they
feel like they get good enough traction
wouldn't they feel like well I kind of
get this now I'm gonna yeah I mean there
was so much more demand than supply of
my time though that any time someone
would churn which it was always because
of success actually like there was never
a case study where it just didn't work
because the format just worked
um you would have some churn but you'd
have like three people that you just had
waiting basically on a waiting list
you're like hey I know you were
interested in this and you can just pull
someone in so that I mean that business
to this day I mean I still run it as
like a side agency now it has an
operator there's you know people
involved and it's a lot more
systematized it was pretty janky at the
time that business has never uh declined
in Revenue since those early days wow
yeah every single month has been flat or
up and then one month over a month yeah
it's never declined because there's
always just been a backlog of I mean
there's infinite demand like even just
today like I saw Alex Lieberman the
morning Brew guy tweeted about this like
hey would anyone be interested and he
said like I texted him I was like oh
what did people say and he was like dude
I got like 20 DMS and so then I ended up
I mean that sparked me thinking about
like oh is there a bigger business play
with this that's disjointed from my time
and so we ended up I co-founded and you
know broader play to do this that's in
stealth right now but scaling up and
we'll be you know 100K mrr within three
months of launch so these businesses are
like there's a big big pie to doing
stuff like that and what about the
newsletter we'll give you the
inspiration of that newsletter
originally was just I want to go a
little little bit deeper so the way I
always thought about it was like Twitter
is super surface level you know the
format in and of itself at the time when
I first started it was 140 characters
per tweet it obviously expanded since
then but it was 140 characters and
people wanted a people wanted a better
format to read my threads so that was
the first thing is I was like oh I'll
just send them to you in your email
inbox so sign up for this and I'll just
send them to you and if you don't like
reading them on Twitter just read them
in your email it'll look nicer it'll
flow better Etc so originally it was
that and then I was like okay I want to
create a deeper connection with these
people than just on Twitter I want to be
able to you know own them in a deeper
way and build a build a better Community
here and so writing in a more deep
construct around the same topics became
what I started writing about in my
newsletter and that was like May 2021
was when I really started putting effort
into that
um and it started with I don't know 10
000 subscribers that were on the list at
the time now it's grown to I don't know
300 000 today
um and it's growing growing fast I mean
it should be at a million I would say
within the next year based on where's
most of the growth coming from
um now it's a combination of top of
funnel from Twitter LinkedIn and
Instagram LinkedIn is probably the
highest Source right now linkedin's like
the new Twitter in terms of the
Arbitrage that's what I'm trying for we
can talk about that I can I can
definitely give you some ideas on that
front but LinkedIn is incredible
Arbitrage right now LinkedIn has a lot
of characteristics that look like what
Twitter was to me in early 2020 in terms
of audience growth capabilities and a
very high value audience growth because
people are professional and they're
there to grow they want to learn they
want to grow and it's not like on
Twitter if you post something you get
like 10 people reply you know three of
them are telling you you're the devil
and you should kill yourself you know uh
five of them like you and then a couple
are in different why do you think
Twitter's so toxic it's only Twitter
so I mean YouTube comments have to get
pretty toxic too right they're nowhere
near Twitter yeah YouTube I believe that
like 95 of YouTube is very positive
interesting five percent of people are
gonna hate no matter what you do but I
would say like 90 95 of people aren't
supportive in some way or want to add
something Twitter and I'll spend like an
hour going through Twitter and just
reading whatever I see and no matter
what it seems more like a 25 it's just
people like just hating on whatever this
person has to say I agree with that I
agree with that number too I mean it's
um
Twitter's interesting it's uh you know I
basically only post positive things like
I I'm in general I'm just a very
positive guy I'm like a happy guy and so
I I avoid controversial things for two
reasons one I don't think about
particularly controversial things I like
posting positive things and two I just
like don't invite that into my life and
so it's just not not part of my brand
um but I still get a bunch of that yeah
and so it's amazing like if I'm getting
that imagine if you post things that are
even borderline so we've tried going not
like controversial but like riding alone
a little bit and you see the engagement
go up so it like it makes sense yeah
we're controversial you get like we'll
see 10 times more growth comments shares
whatever the more extreme you are yes
the Donald Trump Playbook right works
really well right Joe Rogan did it I
mean like it's a tried and true playbook
for Content creators is you like you say
something that is controversial 50 of
people are gonna like it 50 of people
are gonna hate it so much that they
share it saying how much they hate it
which actually just drives your growth
more which it's great it's very it's
actually really really smart as a
Content creation strategy I just don't
want that in my life I have no desire
like I've gotten death threats for
things that I posted that I didn't think
were remotely controversial like I wrote
this thing about
um a kid came and knocked on my door uh
this is like
um
when is this uh 2022 like May yeah um
knock on my door on a Saturday morning I
go to the door
uh young hispanic kid he's like hey you
know I live in the Bronx nearby or I
live in live in Harlem and um I'm you
know trying to make it in the music
industry uh curious if you have any like
you know business so I just want to chat
about business I was like did you come
to my house in particularly like no I
just came to the neighborhood I'm just
like going and knocking on some doors I
live in a nice neighborhood like a nice
residential street in a in Westchester
and um I was like sure yeah I was chat
so I sat on my deck we chatted for a
little while they seemed like a nice
like Earnest kid and I had him back the
next day and he like filmed a music
video I had him back the next day I was
like he's like the hustle to do that
yeah someone to a nice neighborhood
knock on people's door and talk business
that's what I thought man that's yeah
that's what I thought so what I wrote
about that was my that was my kind of
point it was like
rather like if he'd sent me an email 99
chance I wouldn't have seen it or I
would have ignored it because I get a
million emails of people asking me for
different things but he came to my door
and he was like very Earnest polite had
interesting ideas thoughts Etc and it
was very hard to say no to someone to
their face honestly it was just
difficult because I consider myself a
nice person and so him saying like hey
would you be willing to chat for five
minutes I was just like huh that was
interesting he did something different
yeah and so could you sit in a coffee
shop in a nice area and ask people for
business advice maybe could you go do
things like that like just take a
different approach finesse the system a
little bit so I wrote something quickly
about that and it turned into this like
vir actually like the first 24 hours not
much happened and then all of a sudden
it got taken over by this like dark side
of Twitter that turned it into this like
viral outrage that I was gonna put
people in danger that like kids were
gonna get shot they were gonna go to
someone's house and knock on their door
and you know a young hispanic kid goes
to some someone's door in the wrong part
of the country and gets shot and
obviously that wasn't my intention and
you know that scary to me that like
people took it away yeah but it never
never crossed my mind partially like I
understand it was just it was something
that I didn't think of and you know kind
of had a blind spot around and missed
but clearly it wasn't my intention
um and it turned into this like crazy
you know I was getting death threats uh
you know like fortune and Business
Insider decided to write like hit pieces
on it told like said that I declined
comment when they never reached out to
me it like turned into this whole thing
wow and that moment for me
um we had just had our first kid he had
been born like a month before and I'm
getting death threats over something
that I tried to write in a positive vein
and I just realized like yeah the same
for me I'm never I'm not I'm not even
touching anything that's like borderline
like I'm not going anywhere but the
thing is you didn't even know it was
borderline it's like sometimes the
things you say or post you don't even
think are controversial but someone can
interpret it in a way like you never
even thought yeah it got taken in a
direction that I did not anticipate
um but it was a crazy experience of like
okay this is the type of thing that can
happen when you have a platform and when
you have reach and you need to be
cognizant frankly of like I don't want
to endanger anyone that's obviously not
my attention you know what I am thinking
why Twitter attracts more so those
people is because maybe it's showing
more people your post who maybe don't
want to see it like on YouTube
the service recommendations are very
catered to what you've previously
watched it's probably more in line with
with what you enjoy watching yeah uh
whereas on Twitter you're kind of
exposed to a bit of everything so you
see things that maybe are more
provocative yeah there's a bit of mob
mentality that comes out on Twitter
where um with like quote retweets in
particular
um I mean you see this like when when
Cody posted her thing and it went crazy
viral in a negative way it's like the
quote retweet Army comes out and when it
gets picked up in like these little
micro communities that exist on Twitter
like if you get picked up in the like
anti-work Reddit community that exists
on Twitter that was what happened to me
yeah that was what happened with this
it's like the anti-work people took it
as like I'm promoting hustle I'm like
not a big hustle culture guy but they
took it as like this hustle culture bro
is endangering kids by telling them to
go knock on doors and like that wasn't
the point of what I said but it was
taken that way and I wasn't gonna
comment further on it because then
you're just like digging your you know
when yeah I'm a big believer in the
Warren Buffett quote like when you find
yourself at the bottom of a hole just
stop digging yeah and uh so I just did
that I just muted it like went
underground and it was just like a
fascinating few days and an interesting
story to me to say like hey I'm not
touching anything that's borderline
anymore
um but man crazy was that tough for you
to deal with personally like getting all
those hate comments and everything yeah
that's just scary within a newborn it
was mostly just scary because I had the
newborn where I was just like yeah I
don't need this in my life like I have a
newborn kid I'm not trying like I it'd
be one thing if I was trying to be
controversial and then a bunch of hate
came my way and I was like yeah I asked
for this I did this I just didn't mean
to I clearly wasn't trying to get anyone
in trouble or do anything and so it was
like just dicey my wife was pissed did
you ever question your initial tweet
once you started getting all of those
poorly received comments you're like oh
maybe I shouldn't have said that or were
you always still just like no no I mean
I completely stand by what the principle
of the idea was which is that like doing
things differently and finessing a
system like figuring out a different way
to get in the door with people to
network and do these things is smart
like I completely stand by that you know
should I have like sat down and spent
more time thinking about you know the
idea the exact idea of knocking on doors
maybe but like that wasn't really the
point it's just that Twitter as a
platform doesn't have room for nuance
and so if you just read it directly you
would take it in one way when if you
actually just read it with like an open
mind you'd take it in the way I wanted
people to take it
um so I don't know I I mean more than
anything else I think it just took it it
just showed that like you have to assume
that people are going to read the thing
and experience it like by the letter of
exactly what you wrote that they're not
going to be like flexible in the way
that they experience it and if that's
the case and they're going to take it
negatively I'm just not going to post it
is there anything else you posted that
got a totally different response than
you were expecting like to that degree
or was that like no that was that was
like Far and Away the main one I've had
a few things that people have like
gotten outraged by you know in like a
stupid way but that was the only one
that got like really dark
um but I'm pretty flowery man yeah so
how do you approach it now to make sure
there aren't any misinterpretations of
what you have to say I mean most of my
content now since my son was born
frankly most of my content is sort of
about my own personal journey of
experiences struggles and wrestling with
the like changes that come in your life
as you're starting to kind of get older
and experiencing these things my content
lower back pain yeah lower back pain
Next Step just getting old no I mean I
um my life has changed a lot in the
course of the last three four years
right I went from like being like hustle
hustle hustle Finance
um I want to make you know this amount
of money in this many years Etc to
experiencing uh a really incredible and
profound kind of new happiness and
comprehensively Wealthy existence that
is very different for me it's what I'm
writing my book about it's like this
whole idea that you can experience
wealth in a number of different ways
Beyond money and figuring out how to
balance that wealth and build it across
the different seasons of your life is
what I'm sort of committing to as my
life's work like I I have experienced
more happiness and moments of happiness
and also just durable happiness over the
course of the last year and a half two
years since I've made these life of
changes than I had experienced in the 15
20 years prior to it combined and I want
to be able to actually kind of take and
bottle up some of what I've learned from
that journey and help other people
experience that in the same way can you
say some of the life changes that you
made yeah what is that Evolution for you
I mean the biggest thing has been
figuring out the points of Leverage that
exist in the systems that I'm building
like you know working in finance
everything is one-to-one it's like
everything about your life is like I'm
going to put in one unit of input and
it's going to create one unit of output
that unit actually might be pretty large
I'm going to work 90 or 100 hours a week
and I'm gonna make a million dollars you
know on the surface you're like oh
that's great I made a million dollars
well you know if it's 600k that's cash
and you're living in New York City or
you're living in the Bay Area and 50
goes out the door to taxes and your
apartment's six thousand dollars a month
to live in a nice place you're actually
not rich like no matter what anyone says
and everyone's like oh that's a
privileged perspective to live in a city
and say you're not rich on 500k a year
it's just true like in in New York City
if you are making 500 000 dollars a year
and you have a family you are not rich
you're just not I mean it's it's crazy
to think but it's just the case
um and that's just the way that that
whole career path works it's one to one
until you become like a super senior
partner when maybe you're starting to
get more leverage on your time although
the partners worked freaking hard and
we're stressed all the time everything
about my life was that and because my
finances and my career was one-to-one
nothing else in my life could really
Thrive because all my time was sucked up
trying to feed the money machine
everything was like you know the
Sisyphus like from Greek lore were you
like pushing the boulder up the mountain
and as soon as it gets near the top it
rolls back down to the bottom everything
is that and so my physical health
suffered I was like pretty overweight at
the time I can show you guys a before
and after picture I was like pretty
overweight I was stressed my like skin
was bad relationships suffered like you
know what I don't know if it was you
that tweeted this about Goldman Sachs it
must it might it might have been you but
um
I I spent too much time on Twitter yeah
there was a post that I saw about
someone going into Investment Banking
and wanting to go to Goldman Sachs and
they said they looked at the people who
worked there and like 95 of the people
who worked there were overweight bald uh
divorced stressed and they thought why
would I want to go into a career or
that's my most likely outcome yeah and
that's the successful outcome by the way
those guys made money like they were
doing well they were thriving that's
winning
um I'm a big believer in that I don't
think I tweeted that specifically but I
do believe that
um it's basically the I mean the
heuristic is what is the game I'm
playing what is the prize that I'm gonna
win if I win that game and do I actually
want that [__] prize and if you see
that prize and you get a glimpse at that
by looking at the people that are ahead
of you that have won it and you're like
damn that's not a not a pretty prize I
don't necessarily want that life you
know you see them see the person that's
climbed the mountain and they're sitting
up there and they're like stressed about
stupid [__] and you know they're not
happy because they're traveling all the
time and they're relate you know their
relationship with their wife or husband
has suffered because they're not around
and they don't have a relationship with
their kids I mean for me I was like my
one single heuristic in life was that I
want to coach my son's Little League
team and it seems like a stupid small
thing but for me that bleeds out into
everything else in my life because
coaching my son's a little league team
means I have control over my time to be
able to do something like that it means
that I'm the type of father that he
wants to have around to be there in
coaching his teams it means that I'm a
type of husband that is present and able
to go do those things and so that to me
was like am I going to be able to do
that in the life that I'm currently
living and then the trajectory I'm
currently on and if the answer is no
then what am I waiting for I was like I
shouldn't be on this I shouldn't keep
going on this climb what happens to so
many people is I love the like climbing
analogy because I think it applies to so
many things in life what happens to a
lot of people is that you climb and
you're like halfway up that climb of
whatever your first mountain is that
you're climbing in life
and you realize it's not the right
Mountain you're like oh crap I don't
want that prize but it's so scary to
think about climbing back down and
starting on a new Mountain that people
just stay at that halfway point and it
sucks there and they're never going to
excel because they don't really want
that thing and they're not going to put
in the effort to get to the top of it
and so they're just in this limbo their
entire lives and they sit there because
the reality is what it takes to go to
the next one is you have to go down like
you have to go backwards and that's
terrifying in life to go backwards and
go to the next thing so most people
don't do it even when they should and so
for me it was like I'm gonna just do
that and it took having a full-on like
panic attack kind of borderline nervous
breakdown in order to experience that
and realize I needed to make that change
um and that happened for me in May of
2021 I mean I like I woke up I mean I
woke up one morning on the floor of my
house and I couldn't move and I was just
like couldn't breathe chest was
constricted didn't know what you know I
was like didn't know what was going on
had never experienced a panic attack
before and you know is the cumulative it
was kind of like how did you go bankrupt
gradually then suddenly yeah that was
kind of how this happened to me it was
like gradually I just had spent years
kind of doing this thing and assuming
that it was the right thing and then
suddenly it was like I had a
conversation with a friend who basically
said you're living someone else's life
why are you doing this and it kind of
hit me like a ton of bricks and I woke
up and I literally couldn't move and
kind of came out of that and told my
wife I wanted to move back to the east
coast and within 45 days of that
happening I had quit my job we'd sold
our house in California that we had just
built
like a year prior and bought a new place
on the east coast and moved yeah now
what about for her
how how was it for your wife thinking
all right this is a huge life change to
get on board yeah
she it's like this is her credit signed
up for yeah I mean it's it's pretty
crazy because I so that was one of my
biggest fears
I was most scared of not you know I'm
kind of a traditionalist like I believe
that you know my duty as the husband is
to provide for the family like I I just
I sort of believe that I take that on
myself that doesn't mean anything about
what her role is by the way but that's
how I feel about my role that like my
job is to protect and
my biggest fear was that she was going
to like not accept that I wanted to make
this change It's like because I'm
providing while I'm making good money
High Prestige status like it sounds
impressive what I'm doing I'm on these
boards everything things are good why do
you want to change that when I told her
this
she was like yeah I don't know why you
haven't done that already that's that's
stupid and I was like what do you mean
she said well
you don't really like this thing you're
doing and you're making a bunch of money
doing this thing you really like doing
so and you're doing that on the weekend
like what if you did that with all your
time imagine how much money you could
make and I had just never thought of it
that way I was like it sometimes it just
takes that one person giving you the
like New Perspective to unlock how you
think about it do you know Sean Puri
um he's a host of my first million
another oh yeah yeah I actually had a
conversation with him right around that
same time and he was like
I was like I'm thinking of making a big
life change and he's like well what are
the two paths I was like well one path
as I go and you know I just apply to
jobs at an investment fund on the East
Coast we moved back closer to family but
I go take another job and investing the
other path is that I kind of go like out
of my own and keep building these things
I'm building start these different
businesses go double down on myself and
he looked at me and he was like it
sounds like you're choosing between
something that sounds like it sucks and
something that sounds really fun and
interesting so why is there a decision
here and the way he said it it became so
blindingly obvious to me but I had never
thought about it that way until he just
phrased it in those words so it I mean
it just shows you the power of someone
giving you like a different lens through
which to see something because we're
looking at our own lives so zoomed in
every single day you're like I mean
you're the ultimate zoomed in version of
your life you're seeing everything like
on the ground in the weeds Etc and until
you can zoom out either you have to
force yourself to or someone else gives
you the zoomed out perspective you just
miss you like miss all of those things
how difficult is it to get back into
Investment Banking Finance is that one
of those careers where you take like a
year or two off and come back in you're
kind of like the black sheep I'm sure
people think it is my perspective on
that in general is like
it's always worse in your mind than you
actually think it is there's this
tendency in those tracks to be like oh I
have to hit this by this age like vice
president by 27 principal by 30 partner
by 32 start my own fund by 35 and if I'm
not on that track I'm not you know doing
the thing I'm supposed to be doing the
reality is when you go look at
successful people when they're 60 and
you go ask them about their career
you're like hey how'd you get here
they're like well I spent you know seven
years here and then that didn't work
it's then I joined the military and I
got deployed for four and then I came
back and went to business school and
then I started at this one company for
two and then they went under and so then
I ended up here and I've been here for
17 years now I'm the CEO and like there
was nothing trajectory you know driven
or timeline driven and who cares if like
the game is to get to where you want to
get to by the time you're 50 and like be
in a place where you're excited about
your work on a daily basis why do those
timelines of like hitting Forbes 30
under 30 matter I cared so freaking much
about that like I wanted Forbes 30 under
30 more than anything else in the world
I was so upset when I didn't get it I
wanted the realtor 30 under 30. so the
step below step below you know you have
the force you get the amount I mean that
thing was swimming in my head rent free
for a while that I didn't get that I
heard I heard by the way a lot of it's
paid it's definitely paid yeah I mean
all these Venture funds it's like random
associate Adventure films are getting on
this list and you're like bro I like
you're like cold calling people are you
like Forbes 30 under 30s because the
funds are right to get them on there I
get it it's a business it is what it is
but I mean the point is these timelines
that you create around all this stuff
are just [__] and then I think it
applies to the idea of getting back my
general opinion when people are like oh
I want to go you know try this thing
that I'm thinking about for two years or
go try it for a year I'm like yeah go
[__] try it like you can always go
back to your job at Deloitte deloitte's
always going to be hiring smart people
that have done interesting things
McKinsey is always going to be hiring
smart people whatever go back if you're
two years behind the people that you
were previously in line with who cares
it doesn't matter you think a lot of the
best chains and biggest changes in life
comes out of Like a Rock Bottom type
thing or do you think some people need
to hit rock bottom in order to find a
different Avenue and flourish yes I mean
I think there's this concept in so I'm
half Indian
um there's this concept in ancient
Indian culture called The Wheel of Life
which basically says that time in your
life goes through these cycles of
creation destruction and then rebirth
and it's this endless cycle and it's
supposed to be on Cosmic time but I
think that in our lives we experience
that same thing where like creation is
those periods of growth then you end up
kind of getting high on yourself and you
have these periods of Destruction when
things crumble down it's really dark and
really challenging and when you're in
those moments of Destruction the most
powerful thing is to be able to have an
awareness that
after every destruction comes some
rebirth so it's like this whole idea
that when you're in the darkness a lot
of people I saw this quote somewhere
when you're in the darkness a lot of
people think they've been buried when
the reality is they've just been planted
and there's something really really
powerful about that to being able to
outlast those dark periods to just say
like oh this is actually a precursor to
whatever is next for me it's not the end
it's a precursor to whatever's coming
next I don't think it's necessary to hit
rock bottom to make a big change but
it's not shocking that a lot of people
do have that experience before coming to
whatever the new thing is it's it's just
hard to make a big change unless you're
forced into it sometimes because it's so
scary I mean that like I I remember the
fear associated with like leaving this
safe thing that I was good at that
people were telling me I was good at to
go do this like weird Creator thing that
didn't sound impressive to anybody I
mean still like I don't know when I was
leaving my firm my bosses must have
thought I was nuts like I when I told
them I was leaving it was originally
going to be that I was going to go join
another firm on the east coast to be
closer to home and that it made sense
and then I was like actually I'm just
gonna you know do this thing that I'm
like Social Media stuff that I'm doing
and see what happens and I hadn't talked
to them about
you know I didn't talk to them about
this holding company like the businesses
the cash flowing things that I had built
on the side or like some of the things I
was working on on that front I hadn't
talked to them about you know
potentially raising a venture fund and
things I was doing there and so their
view of what I was doing was literally
like tweeting and they were like wait so
you're gonna quit a private Equity job
to tweet that doesn't make any sense
um and so I don't know I mean it's it's
felt very scary on the surface
um but I don't know big big changes it's
like sometimes you just gotta take the
leap how do you remain so positive and
optimistic what is it in you is this
like a change or have you always been
like this uh
I'd say I've always been had a
disposition towards optimism
um I like in my baseball days I was
always big on the idea that you were
always just like one pitch away from
getting out of any bad situation there
were like two types of baseball players
I was a pitcher there were two types of
pitchers there was people who like would
be in a bad situation and be like oh my
God this is a bad situation I'm gonna
give up this many runs this is going to
happen and then there were pitchers who
would be in a bad situation and be like
if I just do one good thing right now
I'm out of this like this is going to be
much better I get a double play whatever
it is and you're out of the situation
and I always viewed baseball that way
and now I always kind of view life that
way where like if you just make one good
decision in the moment and then you make
another one and then you make another
one you can get out of basically
anything and you can start stacking
things in a positive direction and so my
bias has always been in that direction
of just like nothing good comes from
being pessimistic about whatever your
situation is a lot of good comes from
being optimistic and kind of seeing your
path to actually driving out of it
I'm also just really happy man I'm like
my life is very very good right now I'm
like
very very blessed with you know our son
and the experiences it's brought me and
my relationship with my wife and being
close to family for the first time in 12
years there's just a lot of good that
has come into my life from the changes
that I've made
um and so I am just personally extremely
grateful on a daily basis and that
manifests as positivity and happiness I
think it's interesting that you
mentioned only like you didn't mention
any monetary things it was just like
funny like being close to the family the
kids the wife and stuff like that yeah I
mean I like
I'm making a lot more money than I was
when I was working in finance and
frankly a lot more than I would have
made for like the probably five to ten
years after if I just stayed on that
trajectory I mean like the way things
have accelerated the like businesses
that have stood up the opportunities
that have come because of like you know
some uniqueness luck some awareness luck
I would say some of the things that
we've kind of opened up and doors we've
opened up
um
I just you know the financial side has
sort of started to compound in a way
that it wouldn't have and at an earlier
date than it than it would have without
my time actually being involved in it
and so I'm not like spending all my days
thinking about ways to make money and
yet I'm making more than I was and so
that to me I'm like I'm kind of just
separated from it in a certain way where
I'm not thinking about making money
every day which is a nice feeling
how many hours a day do you work now
what is the average day look like we
were having this discussion earlier and
he was laughing about this um so I my
average day
I wake up at 4 30 every single morning
I'm a morning person I go to bed at like
8 30 I'm like a grandpa sure um I wake
up at 4 30 I get my cold plunge which I
know we can have a debate about you want
to go now or you want me to go you want
to go after geez well we know we could
go we could go now I think it's silly
okay I think this is going to be
something we look back on in 30 years
and thinking like what were we thinking
like in what like you think it's bad for
people I don't see the BET yeah I I
don't see how shocking your body with
really absurd cold temperatures would
do anything other than just a quick
adrenaline adrenaline rush maybe
something that a cold shower couldn't do
so I mean it's similar to a cold shower
right like it's but there's actually
something about it ice water but do you
do you like do you not believe the
science is true like this stuff huberman
has put out around like not familiar
okay so like 200 dopamine increase that
lasts for several hours after you get
out
is like a pretty big impact sure that I
personally feel on a daily basis like
the the feeling I feel when I get out of
it and then go start my first kind of
like work stream of the day and the
feeling of energy happiness kind of just
like euphoria that comes from having
done that thing I think it's very real
this might sound stupid but that
dopamine release is is there a sense
that maybe you could use up all of it in
the morning and then you have to like
produce more no I don't think so I mean
so the thing with dopamine is it's like
the the trade-offs of like Pleasure and
Pain right it's like kind of the the
swings of it and so the idea with this
dopamine release is that it's associated
with going through something challenging
or painful to similar to like doing a
really hard workout and then you feel
this feeling of euphoria like go for a
long run Runner's High
um and that versus the dopamine you get
from like a bunch of likes on social
media and you're scrolling you know
you're refreshing you're seeing a bunch
of likes is maybe an unhealthy type
we're doing drugs is maybe an unhealthy
type there's no pain associated with it
you just get the spike until then you
get this massive collapse this is a more
sustained and kind of long duration in
um and and sort of gradual up and down I
think because it's associated with a
painful
challenging experience I think
personally the reason I do it is because
it's doing one tiny very hard thing to
start the day that makes everything else
feel much easier I don't like even if
none of the science is true if there's
no impact on like brown fat or my
metabolism if there's no impact on
dopamine you know if there's no impact
on like my mood any of those things I
would still do it because I just start
the day with this feeling that I can
like tackle anything because it's doing
one thing that I really don't want to do
that I find really challenging and just
conquering my mind around doing it I
don't like proselytize from the
mountains saying like hey you don't do
this Graham you're a loser you're not
you're never gonna make it like that's
ridiculous I don't think that's true at
all but it has positively impacted my
life and so I talk about it because I
think it's you know some some people
might really like it so do you walk me
through here so you get you get out of
the bed and then what in your backyard
you probably have this tub or something
I have so our master bedroom has a deck
that overlooks our backyard and it has a
cold plunge and a sauna on it and so I
will oh like I'm gonna wake up at 4 30
and I go outside onto the deck and right
now it's in New York and so it's cold so
I go outside and open up the thing and
get into the water sit there for three
to seven minutes depending on the day
seven minutes yeah it's not a really
long time that's pretty long seven
minutes is long I mean seven minutes is
tough hasn't it gotten easier though as
time's gone on it doesn't it gets easier
to do during the day like if you went in
when there's sunlight out the sun's on
your face even on a cold day and the
birds are chirping it's rather Pleasant
actually like I will I would enjoy doing
that getting in at 4 30 in the morning
when it's pitch black out and you're
tired and you just got out of bed will
never get easy for me like I hate I mean
every single morning this morning I did
it before flying out here fought it like
just standing at the door to go out onto
the deck being like [__] I don't want to
do this and it's just like open the door
go out and do the things what makes you
do it I I like the feeling of being able
to like control my mind sure and say
that I did the thing that it was
challenging and if I do nothing else
during the course of the very productive
but I know that I like challenged myself
in that way I feel like there's a win I
also my stress response my ability to
manage stress is so so much better now
than it was before I started doing this
because that's what it is you're putting
yourself into this like extreme
stressful environment having to control
your breathing and control yourself and
life is pretty stressful you're going to
have like a bunch of involuntary stress
and struggle that comes into your life
and so my opinion is that by embracing
and getting better like training
yourself with voluntary stress you can
actually be better and more well
equipped for when the involuntary stress
comes just my opinion do you meditate
I've never been able to get into
meditation okay I do like you know
breath work sure and while I'm in the
cold plunge especially because you
really have to
um but I've never been able to get into
a real like meditation habit when you're
in the cold plunge do you focus on the
sensation of the cold or do you just try
to bring your mind elsewhere uh
breathing try to focus on breathing and
then after the cold plunge to get in the
sauna no uh I do sauna at night before
bed you're supposed to like do
um sauna like later in the day um so I
get out do like you know a few minutes
of jumping jacks to try to like warm
myself up naturally
um and then depending on how cold it was
outside I will either like take a shower
to get back to Baseline so that I'm not
like miserable during myself yeah during
my first like working stint or if it's
summer and it's just warm out then I'll
just put on clothes and start my day but
we got sidetracked by uh let's hear it
after that about at 5am I get a Dunkin
Donuts cold brew that's like my go-to
but Duncan best coffee in the world man
best coffee in the world founded by
Benjamin Franklin no that's not true
yeah yeah
um no I there's a Dunkin Donuts right
near our house
and um I just like Duncan has become my
thing that I go to so I get a Dunkin
Donuts and then I sit down at my desk
and so from 5 to 7 30 which is like
before my son has woken up
um I do my first kind of stint of deep
work and for me that's writing always so
right now I'm really working on my book
and so it's either newsletter or book
really
um for like a two and a half hour stint
and then basically like I'll take my son
for a walk for an hour when he gets up
I'll go work out I'll do you know all my
personal stuff that I like spend some
time with my wife
um and then an afternoon I have like one
more two and a half hour stint of deep
work and that's pretty much it
hmm so maybe like great day yeah it's
like five hours of like deep focused
work and then all my walks like I'll
walk my son for about three hours a day
that's all my like thinking time so I
don't consider that work but walking is
when I do my best kind of creative
thinking yeah you listening to music and
stuff like that no silent walks
or while I work
you're asking no silent you found that
to be more beneficial yeah I just like
being able to like hear myself think
um so I've experimented with everything
like classical music I tried I tried
those like binaural beats things for
your brain waves I just like the sound
of just being able to hear things around
me and what about when you write
when I write in the morning I've been
using those binaural beats there's like
this app called brain waves that I like
um huberman recommended it on his
podcast and so I started trying it and
found that it actually really helped my
life what is that it's like a um it's
supposed to be
um something that like kind of optimizes
how you're like the sound actually like
optimizes your brain waves for different
mental states that you want to get into
and that sound you know you can play
like a soothing track over it so like
you don't actually hear like the waves
um you can play like forest sounds or
rain patterning or whatever something
like that
um but it has a whole bunch of different
Focus States you can do like Focus you
can do creative there's like a bunch of
different things and I've actually found
it helps I'm I've never been like a big
believer in those kind of things but it
helps me right do you know the science
behind that no I'd be so curious to try
that yeah I'll send you the app it's
cool it was like 3.99 or something like
that okay it's great I always write to
uh Philip Glass or Danny Elfman hmm
that's good I mean it's I like figuring
out what gets you into your state yeah
is what works I used to be a huge
believer in classical music I would love
writing with classical music now I like
reading with classical music on like a
light in the background
um but it just depends just depends on
the day but yeah I mean I try to like
I'm really trying to optimize for time
with my son right now candidly like in
terms of like what really matters to me
in the world there's this 10-year period
with your kids when you're like their
favorite person in the world it's the
first 10 years of their life after that
they have best friends they have
girlfriends boyfriends they get married
and you're like no longer the most
important person in their life and we
live in a culture where those 10 years
where you are typically is like your
hardest working years and you're gone
most of the time and you're not spending
time with them and I'm in a fortunate
state where I can actually flip that on
a Ted and really take advantage of the
fact that I have a you know a life in a
kind of like business structure where I
can really be around and really Embrace
this time with them and it's special I
see that thing circulating online of
time spent with other people that was me
that was you yeah yeah where it's in the
beginning it's like family and then it
you know dissipates off spouse spikes
around 20 through you know 60 or
whatever and then the time spent alone
was something where I think from 30 to
35 you spend the least amount of time
alone and then every year after that
just creeps back up it's really
interesting yeah those charts were
fascinating I mean I stumbled upon the
combined chart which had been out for
years because it was like a 2019
American time use survey I think that
they use the data around and I had seen
the combined chart a few times but it's
so uh like clumsy with all the lines on
it's like very hard to actually see what
it's saying and you kind of just look at
it and you're like okay interesting and
the dado is available to download so I
just downloaded it was like oh let me
look at what each of these lines looks
like so I just put it into an Excel
spreadsheet like brought back my analyst
hat like opened Excel for the first time
in three years and separated it out and
I was sitting it was like a Saturday
morning I was sitting there and I was
like showed it to my wife I was like hey
this is kind of cool right I should put
like I should post these graphs this is
like pretty interesting and she was like
yeah that is actually pretty interesting
I posted it and it went I mean pretty
Mega viral right really really blew up
um but yeah I thought it was fascinating
I mean they'll like the couple that
really jumped out to me were the
children one which is what I just talked
about like you get very very short
period of time
um and then the alone one is like yeah
that's the one for me that really wow
yeah I mean you got to get comfortable
with yourself because you're gonna a lot
of time alone over the course of your
life and most people are terrified of
being alone the idea of being bored in
2023 is why I mean it's like impossible
when's the last time you were really
bored like you have your phone with you
and so you just like pop it open if your
phone dies and you're like on a plane
and your phone's dead and you don't have
your laptop and there's no TV in front
of you it's like what am I gonna take
Sky Mall there's not even Sky Mall
anymore
out of business being bored is like I
actually sat on a cross-country flight
next to a guy like a few years ago that
for six hours
didn't take out his phone didn't read a
book didn't watch anything on TV
literally just stared straight ahead for
six hours and I thought about calling
the FBI I was like bro this guy is gonna
kill us like this is terrible imagine
like an old man no yeah like 45 50. I
don't know like did you say anything to
him no I I was terrified I'm actually
not kidding I was terrified just like
looking straight ahead
like with a pleasant look on his face
just stared Straight Ahead not eyes
closed didn't sleep like literally just
stared and we were in the exit Row in
the like bulkhead and so it was
literally a wall like it wasn't like
there was people watching like there was
interesting things like he literally
just looked straight ahead and like
shifted a few times didn't go to the
bathroom I mean crazy crazy I don't know
if you must have been meditating or
something
um do that for six hours or maybe he had
like been in jail and spent time in
solitary until he just knew how to do
that but we're really bad at being bored
humans right now I mean I'm terrible at
it so like when I go on these walks
that's kind of my way of like finding
that boredom in myself you know what
it's interesting I deleted Tick Tock
because it was sick for the full day and
I was in bed and so I would kill time by
watching tick tocks yeah and one day of
doing that I found myself the next day
instinctively every time there's a spare
moment pulling up my phone and opening
it up every time so I deleted the app it
took me a few days to like come off of
that yeah of just constantly needing to
grab have my phone for any spare moment
that I'm not like engaged in something
yeah I mean it's kind of scary like you
look at your screen time and it's part
of your job yeah so like part of me
justifies the amount of time I spent on
Twitter or these things as like I kind
of have to do this it's part of my job
um but it's kind of scary and the amount
of impact it has in our life and on our
behaviors like the fact that when
something is going but I mean you
probably have this with videos but like
when you post a tweet and it's going
viral and you're like oh let me just
check let me just check let's go let me
just check what's happened like it's
controlling your mind and you don't need
to check nothing new has happened it's
just gonna have another 100 likes or
whatever the number is
um but we've let it come to that I mean
I don't have tick tock on my phone
because I don't want the Chinese
influencing my brain but
um that's a separate you know National
Security risk and everything that'll
eventually get gotten rid of I think I
don't know I just get a whole bunch of
dumb crap though it's like on tick tock
on Tick Tock I just my issue with Tick
Tock frankly was like when I first
opened it for the first time they must
have patterned me you know like 32 year
old male I don't know what like it would
have patterned me as whatever the
algorithm was but it was literally just
like half naked women on there every
single swipe yeah and
um I was like I can't open this at home
because my wife is gonna like she's
gonna be like I'm gonna like open it on
the couch to like look at Tick Tock and
it's just gonna be a bunch of like girls
dancing and I'm gonna be like I didn't
look at a bunch of like I don't follow
these people I don't know and it's just
gonna lead to like a bunch of you know I
don't I don't I don't need that so
um I also don't have Tick Tock the one I
found very interesting I started getting
recommended uh you would know this uh
but Jack I think you've seen this the
North Korea videos
where they're going through and showing
just how like great it is oh really yeah
so you are patterned as like a North
Korea sympathizer I don't know what it
was trying to put that information out
there maybe but but it's trying to
pivoted is like someone who took um
someone who took like a camera in there
like the iPhone started like just
posting it yeah and showing like great
streets and like everything is calm and
like walking around and like it looked
so peaceful like a really nice New York
City with no trash everyone is friendly
like and it was weird that those kept
getting like recommended over and that
is weird over and over again and then I
didn't think much of it I thought oh man
this is weird until I went online and
there was a YouTube video about uh that
was also like getting pushed alongside
with that people were like are you
getting these recommended too and
they're like yeah I am it's weird that
is weird yeah no I haven't I I hadn't
gotten that in in weeks was this a while
ago or when was this a month ago oh
that's weird man I mean the thing that
scares me about tick tock just in all
seriousness is like right now
we're in the midst of a pretty chaotic
banking situation in the United States
um I'm sure you've talked about this in
different videos
um what terrifies me is a lot of these
crises are propagated by fear with
people and human behavior actually leads
to these things right Silicon Valley
Bank like I almost got caught up in it
right my Venture fund was banked at
Silicon Valley Bank we had to get money
out at the last second to escape it
um it's driven by like people panicking
and pulling money from these things in
addition to all the interest rate stuff
that has happened and the changes and
you know unrealized losses Etc
um
if China like Tick Tock is a state-owned
business effectively like all Chinese
businesses are whether they say they are
or not
and in a situation where like they are
one of our main adversaries and they can
during a period of already people being
on edge make a tiny tweak to the
algorithm that starts surfacing for a
hundred million Americans a bunch of
fear-inducing content about the banking
situation that further leads to economic
challenges in the country or to a
banking collapse that's a Cyber attack I
mean that's like a full that's War
um that is propagated through an app
that is controlled by one of our main
adversaries and that to me is like
that's scary couldn't you say the same
thing about Twitter because I've heard a
lot of things that the bank run started
on Twitter but they're but Twitter is
not controlled by anybody so Twitter is
people there's people but it could be
their algorithms but Twitter's owned by
yeah I mean maybe one but Elon Musk
doesn't have incentives for the U.S
changing system to collapse and
Twitter's banned in China so like China
has banned all of the American apps from
from having influence in their country
and we have I'm more so saying that it
makes it very easy for information to
spread very quickly I totally agree to I
totally agree with that and it did it
did happen on Twitter you saw it with
Silicon Valley Bank stuff but it's not
controlled by one of our main
geopolitical adversaries did you see
that that video that went pretty viral
of the Twitter owner or sorry The Tick
Tock owner CEO that was asked if their
kid has Tick Tock and they're like no my
kid doesn't have Tick Tock oh no I
didn't yeah there's a clip that went
super viral of that I think it depends
how old the kid is there okay I think
the kid's 11. yeah yeah I love it we're
too young
what age would you hold your kid a phone
uh a phone probably eight to ten to be
honest eight to ten because I feel like
they would need to have a means of
communication they're just always on
them Tick Tock what's the age that they
put on 13. so why would the tick tock
owners say like oh yeah my 11 year old
should get Tick-Tock I I think 13. he
attends young for a phone you think so I
think they're if they're out because
he's very laissez-faire as far as like
parenting goes so far until he has kids
man
yeah
no I'm not gonna get picked up you're
not gonna fly first class on your own
I don't know like tick tock
preferably not at all but like but
they're gonna be exposed to it in one
way or another whether it be it's you
know reels or shorts I mean it's it's
there yeah
um
parenting 13. until I had a kid and then
I was like
so no you get everything I'm just like
oh oh [__] oh god dude I mean it's scary
you like you put a kid out into the
world and uh
I mean it's it's basically like whatever
they feel you feel 10x like if they
experience Joy you feel it even more
it's like Amplified in you you feel so
happy for them but if they feel pain
it's way worse for you you're just like
your heart just break I mean I can't
imagine like my kid getting bullied at
school and coming home and being upset
like I would want to go kill whoever
that kid was and that's like a
terrifying thing about being a parent
but it also makes you I mean like for me
you know if my kid falls and like hits
his face his face on a coffee table
there because he's trying to learn how
to walk and you know he's not stable and
so he just like fell and hit his face
and he like had a little he can cut on
his lip and he was upset for a minute
and then was done and now I'm like oh
[__] like grab him every time but the
following is actually part of him
learning how to walk like he needs to
experience the pain in order to like
learn that if he crosses his feet he's
probably gonna fall flat on his face and
it's gonna hurt and that's part of it
but for me I'm just like now I don't
want him to experience that pain again
because it was really sad I felt really
bad and what if he hits his head harder
than that or he like hits a step and it
cracks his head open like that is
terrifying so I think that well the
whole you become like a much stricter
parent a certain way and like less
laissez-faire from just having a kid and
becoming more nervous naturally I think
would you agree with this quote I heard
it I thought it was kind of interesting
that humans experience emotions on a
range of zero to ten then you get
married and then the range goes from
negative 10 to 20. and then you have a
kid and then the range just gets
completely obliterated it's negative
Infinity to Infinity yeah I think so
actually it's a good quote I like that
I'm gonna start using that I mean I I
everyone has their own range everyone
has their own like point on the spectrum
that their Baseline is too like my
um my mom is a highly emotional person
my mom like if there's a scale of one to
ten my mom's probably like a nine on the
emotion scale
of where like her Baseline is like she's
highly prone to not in like a weird way
but she's
um she experiences emotion very deeply
and like she'll be very sad about
something you know for years afterwards
and we'll continue to talk about it and
feel real emotions around it I am like
much more of a stoic like I'm probably
like a two and
our relationship
um has had challenges at times because
she is experiencing something as a very
emotion-inducing event and my natural
disposition is to be stoic about it and
so when we're trying to communicate
around that thing it's very challenging
and so like in a relationship in a
loving relationship and an intimate one
if your wife is an eight or nine and
you're at a two you're gonna have to
really communicate around that Gap
because it's going to be a struggle and
when you have kids and they get added to
that mix if you're going to be on
different ends of the spectrum it's
really really hard my wife and I are
both pretty low on the emotion scale
actually naturally and so with our kid
while maybe our like the amplitude of
the wave has expanded we're able to
manage it because we're sort of aligned
on our General Baseline what role does
your wife play in your business your
life how does she massive role I mean
um she
I mean I would argue like none of this
is possible without her in it
um both indirectly and directly I mean
my wife is um she's a fashion designer
um she worked for the first eight years
I guess it was 10 years 10 years of her
career at different companies under the
Gap umbrella so she was at Athleta I've
been in Republic at this new brand they
launched
um she worked on some of the Yeezy stuff
when Kanye West was with them like done
a bunch of different things
um when our son was born she decided she
wanted to spend the first year like take
time off to spend the first year and
really focus on being a mom and now
she's going back and working with a
startup brand kind of part-time in the
time that she can balance around around
being a mom but if not for her being
like as actively involved and as amazing
as a mother as she is I would never have
the freedom to be able to pursue these
different things that I am pursuing
right now especially around like my own
kind of like health and wellness Journey
which has become a big part of the
things I write about you know like my
book has a big component around physical
wealth like building well in your life
in different ways and so part of that is
Guinea pigging all this stuff on myself
and experiencing it being able to
storytell around it and without her you
know willingness to kind of allow me to
kind of go on these Journeys and really
like uh you know help me go on these
Journeys and be able to do it travel to
things like this Etc none of it would be
possible so she's a huge part of it
she's not directly involved in any of my
business stuff which is a cognitive
cognizant uh you know like an active
decision that we've made that we didn't
want to like work together
um because we like to be able to like
separate church and state if you will
um I think it's personally it's just
like works better for us but um I mean
she's like the CEO of our household in a
big big way when when you got married
did you guys get do a prenup
no no uh my wife comes from a
um
wealthy background I don't think she
would be mad at me saying that I mean
her father was a successful entrepreneur
had sold a couple companies in the
biotech space
um if we were to have had a prenup at
the time of our marriage it would have
been Pro her because I we were high
school sweethearts we've been dating
since she was a freshman in high school
I was a sophomore in high school when we
met
um and had dated all the way through
gotten married you know I was like a
analyst or Associated at my fund
um I don't think we wouldn't have
entertained a prenup I have tons of
friends who have now gone and gotten
prenups and are pretty you know
emotionless about it
um I don't think it would have been an
easy conversation for us to have
personally yeah especially as high
school Suite after that long yeah I
think at that point yeah what do you
attribute to the success of that because
very few High School sweethearts really
last yeah this long I think part of it
is luck
um and I don't say
um
I don't say that there wasn't work along
the way but there were people who were
really only fit for like one season of
your life
if you take that your life kind of comes
and goes in Seasons you have different
experiences you change you're different
from one season of X there are people
that are only really meant for one
season of that you have friends that are
like that you have friends who are like
a great friend in high school and you
really needed them in that fun kind of
effervescent stage of your life now that
you're building or you're doing
something different they're not maybe
the right friend for that and that's
okay you have these friends that come
and go the relationships that come and
go like that
there are marriages for some people that
come and go like that
um we've been very fortunate in that we
met when she was 14 I was 15. and for
whatever reason cosmically you know or
individually emotionally we've
somehow matched and grown together
through all the different seasons that
we've gone through the first season of
that was me being a high school
douchebag and just like you know
thinking way too highly of myself and
being kind of like an arrogant prick at
the time at age 16 and not being the
type of person I'm proud of today but
her really like
sticking with me through that and
helping me grow as an individual and
then you know the next season was like
we were in college and we were far apart
from one another she was in New York
City I was in the Bay area and we kind
of were doing our own thing and really
like struggling through long distance
then we got engaged and she moved out to
the Bay area and we had our first season
of like living together and that was
this new exciting thing
um and now we're in the next season of
that which is like raising a child
together and so I feel like at every
stage we've sort of grown closer and
gotten to know each other better in a
different context and in a different way
and experience new challenges together
but a lot of it is just luck that we've
been fortunate that we have grown
together I think it's pretty intentional
I would say most people are more
compatible than they think I think
there's kind of just a threshold that
needs to be met as far as compatibility
goes for a lifelong partner and it's not
that high like for the most part if two
intentional people care enough about the
relationship to make it work they can
make anything work so I would say you're
probably not giving yourself yeah
equally want to make sure work one wants
to make it work more than the other well
of course both people have to be so you
don't believe in the idea of the one I
want to but you don't think I do no I
don't either for what it's worth and my
wife like maybe would punch me in the
face for saying that you know like
saying that on air but I I don't believe
that that's true I think that it
basically I think a lot of people are
miserable through life because they
believe in that idea because they're
looking they're spending their entire
life like waiting for that perfect thing
to just show up and plop itself onto
their lap when the reality is
what actually makes a great relationship
is taking the imperfect thing and
working at it to make it as perfect as
you possibly can and if you're so
Blinded By looking for the perfect you
just ignore all the things that are
imperfect that come along it's like you
know you you know you see the like
you're looking for a perfect shell on
the beach or whatever and you never find
one well there were these other shells
that were pretty damn good that you
could have polished and it's always
going to cut a little bit or something
yeah exactly and that's part of what
makes these things interesting frankly
is the like the growth and the learning
that comes from dealing with those I
mean like I said like I spent many years
of our relationship as a person that I'm
not proud of today but part of what
makes us so strong today is that we've
got through that and that I had to
change and that she changed with me and
that she like taught me to grow up and
those those experiences are a big part
of who we are today as a relationship
and as a unit so I I mean I also don't
believe in the whole idea of the one and
I I agree with you like I do think
um a lot of people would be much better
off by like going a layer deeper on some
of the people that they don't think are
the perfect fit for them right away so
our average viewer demographic is let's
say like a 24 23 year old guy what
advice would you give to the average
person listening on relationships no in
general
it could be relationships sure yeah sure
it could be relationships just something
that you think would really help them
out yeah I mean on relationships
expand your definition of attraction
I think that at 24 at 25 everyone I know
that's that age their definition of
Attraction is entirely physical and I
get it like I love you know like my wife
is extremely attractive I love that like
I think that's an amazing feature
um but if you don't expand your
definition of Attraction you're going to
be
um living a life that is really
unfulfilling in the long run if you if
you find a partner that's purely based
on physical attraction because the
reality is
you know you might find that super
exciting for a few weeks for a few
months maybe for a year but eventually
it's not gonna be the most exciting
thing in the world and you need to have
layers of Attraction with an individual
as you're building a relationship that
go well beyond the physical attraction
there needs to be spiritual attraction
there needs to be emotional attraction
with a person things that just go well
beyond that physical attraction and if
you're not looking for that if you're
not thinking about that when you're on
the dating circuit when you're going out
and meeting people you're just going to
go down the path of dating the person
that you think other people will think
is impressive so many of my friends that
are like 24 25 these guys that played
baseball with whatever they're like the
people are dating it's not because they
really care about the person it's
because they think their friends will
think it's impressive that they're
dating this person
and that's just a recipe for disaster
I've had some friends marry that person
eventually and quickly realize that it's
not a good not a good move so I've
experienced that too I never dated that
person uh mostly because it was
unattainable while I was in high school
but back in the day I remember everyone
would be like oh my God this girl is so
attractive this and she plays soccer
she's really gonna talk or something
like that like this is the girl right
and I would find myself attracted to
this person my medic desire man like a
couple years later I'm like what am I I
didn't find them attractive but nothing
about them I found attractive it was
just the fact that I just heard that
they're so great and I'm like yeah sure
they're great yeah and you you wanted to
be able to tell your friends that you
yeah because it would sound so cool yeah
yeah and look I get it like part of it
is
um everything is status signaling right
like we're monkeys at the end of the day
and so status signaling matters and like
my medic desire like that desire to want
things because other people want them is
a real thing it's like an actual social
psychological phenomenon but I think
that that like expanding your definition
of what you were attracted to about
someone and really thinking more deeply
about that at a young age is is an
important thing because if you find the
right life partner
I mean your life's success or misery is
so driven by the person that you choose
to marry and the person that you choose
to partner with whether you marry them
or not like if marriage is something you
don't believe in okay but whoever you
choose to partner with that can be your
best friend you know the person you
spend all your time with your partner
whatever it is your success or misery is
so driven by that person
it's unbelievable and people don't I
mean it can be a 10x like massive unlock
for your life like it is for me I mean
my wife is like all of My Success
anything that we accomplish as a family
is because of her
or it can be a huge drag and it can lead
to a ton of misery and a ton of
Heartache that holds you back from
achieving anything that you want to
achieve
um so I think just being deliberate
about that is a huge piece of advice I
would have so what piece of advice would
you have philosophically for the average
20 to 24 year old
philosophic because you said you kind of
err on the side of being a stoic yeah
which is actually really interesting
yeah learn to embrace boredom at a young
age learn to embrace silence and being
in your own mind at a young age go for
more walks I mean I like go if you can
learn to and train yourself to just go
for like a 30 minute walk every day
without feeling like you need to listen
to a podcast or like do some
self-improvement activity during it I
really think you're going to start
unlocking more creative and non-linear
outcomes in your life that's like the
big goal of life is to have non-linear
outcomes in anything you're doing if you
were to like take a step back and break
it down non-linear outcomes are what
we're all looking for like linear
outcomes are fine right I'm working an
hour I'm making this much money I'm like
working out I'm getting this much
benefit from it I'm eating this I'm
getting this much benefit those are all
linear outcomes great what I really want
is for me to like work that five hours
and I'm making more money than I was
making before way more or I want to be
able to work out for 15 minutes and get
the hours benefit like I want those
non-linear outcomes and I personally
think that being bored and having those
periods of silence and quiet time is
when you figure out an identity identify
what those non-linear opportunities are
what are some of the things that you
learned from Tim Cook
explain that
so very unique yeah
um so Tim and I met at the gym
um It's Kind of a Funny Story I mean I
was like working in my first job coming
out of school is at that at that private
Equity Fund I was working really hard
um I wanted to make sure I was in the
office by 6 30 every morning and so I
still wanted to work out because it was
still important to me and one of my big
hobbies and so that meant I had to get
to the gym by five every day
um in order to get to the office by 6
30. so I'd show up at the gym Equinox in
Palo Alto
um at five every single morning there
was like eight people that would show up
at that same time every day so like you
got to be kind of crazy to show up at
opening time you know like people were
waiting outside at 4 55 to let the doors
you know they'd be like banging on the
doors to get let in and you know you
kind of get close to those people
talking to them every single morning
it's the same group of eight people
because no one's that crazy a lot of
people would trickle in at 5 30 not that
many at 4 55.
um and so I talked to the people after
about six months I'd been talking to
this group of people and I was talking
to one of the gentlemen and someone came
up to me and was like do you know who
that is I said no I said that's Tim Cook
the CEO of Apple and I was like damn
[__] like I didn't know that I've been
talking to this guy for six months I was
probably sounding like an idiot what
were you talking about it's just random
gym stuff I don't know like what do you
talk to about like oh what you know what
are you doing like what you know what's
going on like how are you doing today
with just like basic stuff you're like
shaving in the mirror and you're like
talk whatever the news is of the day
like random things it's just people
um but I wasn't in Tech and so like I
wasn't investing in Tech I didn't know
Tech I hadn't really come through the
tech world and so and he didn't wear
glasses in the gym until like I didn't
recognize him he just didn't he didn't
look familiar to me and he wasn't nearly
as famous then as he is now like he was
the new CEO at the time his you know
prominence hadn't quite grown as much as
it has today obviously
um and then I figured it out obviously
from that interaction and so I cold
emailed him I talked to him that morning
about an article that I had
um seen and I cold email them uh and
sent the article and just said hey I'm
guessing your email address here why
wouldn't you just bring it up the next
day
um I just like I went back I just talked
to him about the article
um like 10 minutes before I got into the
office and I was like I'm just gonna try
to send him the article okay
um because I just talked about it let me
just kind of shoot the shot and so I
guessed an email address sent it and
within five minutes he replied and was
like oh thanks for sending this you
guessed the right email address
um you know whatever quirky response and
so then I um I basically then just was
like okay now that he's replied once I
might as well just like
be bold here and so I asked if he'd be
willing to get a get a coffee and you
know chat like I'm not looking for a job
I'm not looking for anything but I'd
love you know your science perspective
spell that out yeah I was like I'm in
and he knew I was in a role that I liked
because we had been talking about
different work stuff at the gym
um and he was willing to do that so we
ended up having breakfast and uh
basically it led to what you know what
has now been 10 plus a year like
nine year I guess
um like wonderful relationship
mentorship and
um you know I've gotten to do a lot of
amazing things as a result of him uh
went to the Berkshire Hathaway annual
meeting with him one year which was
amazing got to meet Warren Buffett and
really yeah I mean it was like
incredible
um and he's just been like an amazing
amazing influence and you know
involvement in my life he was a big part
of my decision to
um you know make my life change and
pursue these things that I'm really
interested in he's been very supportive
um and you know I'm not like texting him
every day asking for advice it's not
like the mentor the formal version of
Mentor that people talk about like hey
will you be my mentor
um but he's had an amazing influence in
my life and in a very very positive way
and I think for me
the biggest thing that I've gleaned from
at least our relationship building was
that it was never driven by any like
transaction I wasn't looking for him to
invest in a company I wasn't trying to
get a job at Apple you know like I
wasn't looking for anything from him
other than to just learn
and people in those situations and in
those roles all they get all day 24 7 is
people wanting something from them it's
just someone coming with their hand out
with their hand out asking for something
and so I think
in those situations when you can
actually just come from a place of being
genuine and not looking for something
not transactional not quid pro quo it
stands out and so I think I mean the
fact frankly that I didn't know who he
was for the first six months like I've
joked about this with him later
um stood out because I wasn't just like
you know there were tons of people then
over the like months until he wasn't
able to go to the gym anymore at a
public gym where like you know some guy
would walk in and be like hey Tim I want
to put you on my startup idea and like
okay dude it's probably not gonna work
right like you just very transactional
it's just kind of a weird thing yeah
shoot me an email like I'm sure I'll get
back to you so that I mean that's it's
been an amazing amazing relationship in
my life I'd say the most interesting
thing I learned from him
um was probably like in his own career
Journey the role of
kind of like this
this idea that Steve Jobs had around not
being able to connect the dots looking
forward have you heard Steve Jobs's
speech on this so Steve Jobs obviously
was a huge Mentor in Tim's life
um Steve gave this speech at Stanford in
2005 the commencement speech and he
talks about the fact that
there are these dots in your life like
these events that happen and you never
know how they're going to connect
looking forward like when you do
something you never know how it's going
to lead to the next good outcome you
can't predict those things in in kind of
looking at it forward but you can
looking back so his example of that
Steve Jobs was that he took a
calligraphy class after he dropped out
of college
he walked into a calligraphy class and
like beautiful handwriting and stuff and
he says there was no possible way that
was going to benefit my life that's like
a ridiculous skill set No One's Gonna
need to be a calligrapher but then 10
years later when they were making the
first Macintosh computer it was the
first computer that had beautiful custom
typefaces and fonts and that was driven
by his love of calligraphy and so he
couldn't have connected those two dots
from taking a calligraphy class to
building the first computer that had
that looking forwards but looking back
you can say oh my God the fact that I
did that class has led to this
incredible Innovation that we've created
and Tim's was he was at IBM like Rising
through the ranks as an executive there
just like kind of plugging away and he
ended up leaving to go join this startup
at the time compact which was like a
small computer startup uh and he
happened to go do that that was like the
crazy decision that he made because IBM
was like this great big company he was
doing really well at it Etc went to
Compaq when Steve Jobs was looking
through resumes for someone to bring on
for operations at Apple he looked
through the resume and he saw Tim Cook
and he saw IBM and he was like oh big
company guy I don't want you know I
don't want a big company guy he's not
going to be a fit but then he saw that
he had left IBM to go to Compaq and he'd
only been there like a little bit of
time and that in his mind triggered
something like oh there's something
different about this guy that he left
IBM to go join this weird computer
startup maybe he's interesting we should
have a conversation with him they had
the conversation and obviously now the
rest is history and so it's another
amazing example of just that of like he
never would have known that by making
the decision to leave and go to this
computer startup which has now obviously
failed would lead to this incredible
career trajectory and path that he's had
but in Reverse you can look at that and
say like oh okay I made this decision
and it led to something good
so it's just these like these examples
of following your intuition around
things yeah like where you think
your interest line where your passions
lie that I think create these amazing
amazing outcomes so what are some of the
questions that you would ask Tim
how do you make decisions around you
know challenging things that happen like
I would never ask him around Apple
questions I don't know that I've ever
heard I mean I don't think I've ever
asked him a single question about Apple
mind or relationship with him hey
because I just don't care I'm not
investing in Apple stock it doesn't
matter to me and B I'm much more
interested in general in how people make
decisions like you know for him he's
like a head of state right like you're
the CEO of one of the biggest companies
in the world you're effectively a head
of state like you have to make decisions
with so many complex
variables constituents involved all of
these different things like how do you
how do you actually do that and so
learning from him
you know how he thinks about like having
one or two guiding principles or values
like a razor that allows you to cut
through the noise and make decisions in
those contexts was really really
fascinating to me so there's more things
like that and you know like look he's
very connected in political circles and
he knows a lot of interesting people so
just like talking to him about like what
different people are like and you know
what they are thinking about what does
the future look like for them what are
they interested in like that kind of
stuff I find really really interesting
what's the most surprising thing that
you've learned in general no from that
from that relationship with him
um
I would just say how
deeply principle driven he is as an
individual
um has been surprising me my perception
of CEOs prior to knowing him
um was that they're very Machiavellian
um
and
everything is just about you know profit
and you know who cares at the end of the
day and people say that about Tim
um you know people look at him and say
that from the outside looking in that
he's like entirely about profit and
makes all these decisions I have
experienced him to be extraordinarily
value driven
um
and really Guided by like you know a
higher good in what he thinks he's doing
you know on a day-to-day basis and the
impact that Apple can have on Humanity
in this you know as a society do you
think that if you are so fixated on
profit like that is what you put above
all else that that will yield better
returns than if you focus on something
else maybe
um short term probably
short term I think you probably like if
you focus on profits and you like are
optimizing all the different things yeah
I think you can probably have a really
good outcome in the short term around
that my guess is long term the companies
that endure
um you know need to have like an X
Factor something that kind of is driving
them uh on a deeper level in the in the
long long term yeah I feel like it's
hard to stay competitive after a certain
point because Innovation I think will
eventually take over yeah and it's hard
to like profit uh Innovation right like
I mean that's the big knock on Apple now
right just as a company the knock on
Apple is like it hasn't really innovated
around new products since the iPhone and
you know can they continue to innovate
and create the next iPhone without Steve
Jobs at the helm or without Johnny Ive
or whoever the big people were that kind
of really drove that stuff and they've
done an amazing job of really profiting
from their core and like the iPhone and
the services business like it's growing
and all these things they've done really
well and can they continue to do that
um I mean the reality is like most
companies don't last that long right
there's like you know how many companies
have lasted 200 years most of them are
in Japan which is just like an
interesting there's this new article
that just came out of study of companies
that have lasted 200 years like 60 of
them are in Japan it's like this crazy
but isn't that because they passed down
their businesses from generation to
generation very if you sell yeah it's my
understanding yeah maybe maybe
um and a bunch of them had like under
200 employees I found that really
interesting they're mostly small like
kind of stay under the radar there's
probably I'm sure there's like you
reasons that are kind of driving these
different things but
um will a company that exists today in
50 years exist in the exact same format
I don't know it's like really really
hard to bet on that I find that when you
look at the S P 500 1980 crazy today all
the top companies I think besides like
Exxon yeah just not there yeah it's
completely don't exist yeah and I love
watching the thing the visual is a
visual yeah where it shows the company's
growing in like Google spikes up but
then IBM takes over yeah three-fold yeah
just tanks what company that is enormous
today do you think will not exist in 25
years it will not exist at all
oh geez uh if you were to guess one net
Netflix would have to
I wouldn't even count like of the really
big companies like of the Facebook
Google Amazon Apple Google's here to
stay a hundred thousand percent but we
don't we don't know do you think so
necessarily so I I might put my money on
Google because I would say like what if
you know open AI completely kills them
that's what I would be worried about but
then again Google's very uh Nimble to
like adjust they have a thousand layers
of middle managers sitting there though
yeah I don't know Google has really
YouTube I mean yeah that's true with
YouTube except if you're a tick tock in
which case YouTube can kind of like
compete a little bit yeah
um Netflix is pretty big I feel like
it's it's gonna be hard for Netflix to
innovate in such a way to be around 25
years so that's possible Google I have a
good feeling about it yeah Microsoft
though it's just a beast I don't know
how it's such a beast it's amazing
you're still doing so well so well um
yeah yeah that's possible Apple I I
think I I think I got money on Apple
yeah I think so too I mean it's just
they'll have to navigate succession
Tesla yeah Tesla would be the
interesting one I don't think
Tesla will be around I don't think so
too much competition and
and I mean I'm gonna get like attacked
by all the people that are like it's not
a car company it's not a car company but
it kind of is a car company
um I don't know electric vehicles it's
like every single company is going to
make electric vehicles and you can't
tell me that Toyota is not going to be
able to manufacture electric vehicles
better than Tesla like they're the gurus
of manufacturing like Kaizen it was
created there
um and so I just I think it's gonna be
really cheap I mean it's just gonna be
challenging to compete on just being the
electric vehicle in the market the cool
of it I think it's got to be so many
full self-driving yeah in which case how
quickly could other companies and this
is coming from someone I have two Teslas
I think they're great cars I love them I
think they're great
um but does this full self-driving
really full self drive or does it like
randomly break on the highway
yeah
it's terrifying sometimes
um the highway speeds are great when you
put it on basically yeah adaptive cruise
control essentially yeah
um but yeah I don't know I I wouldn't be
shocked I wouldn't be shocked I mean
like Elon Musk is an interesting
character uh but will he like have an
Icarus moment where he flies a little
too close to the Sun and you know gets
melted and crashes I don't know I would
love happened a lot through history I'd
love to see Apple come out with a car
Apple would make a really really good
apple car uh Google car I think would be
really cool no waymo yeah yeah yeah we
get a lot of those just drive into those
little test cars oh yeah do they have
them here yeah because they did a lot of
them in Scottsdale yeah Phoenix I used
to try in um in the Bay Area they used
to run a lot of their tests obviously
right around Google's campus and um they
had one that would do a loop on like my
drive from the gym to work every morning
I would see it and I used to always like
it was on a two-lane road and I used to
always like speed up run in front of it
try to like break a little bit because I
was like oh man what if it hits me like
if I get into an accident and I come out
and I'm like Oh my neck Google hit me
like I could get a big settlement out of
Google if you pay me 10 million dollars
I won't say
Josh
never worked out unfortunately but never
know but I think the Apple car would be
insane insane and imagine they came up
with an apple house
like a prefab technology do you think
people be scared of that kind of thing
no I don't know Amazon people would be
scared but Apple no yeah Amazon I feel
like people would be paranoid it's
constantly listening to them but Amazon
like it would restock everything in your
house that you needed at all times it
could be kind of sick yeah but a pre
prefab Apple house would be sick exactly
I think it makes sense and then for
Apple to also get into banking that's
one thing I really wish that Apple card
was more successful and yeah integral to
like the banking side of things what do
they do they partnered with Goldman
Sachs right I don't think it was it was
many people embraced it but I think it
was because of their association with
Goldman Sachs I think obviously people
think yeah they wanted like an apple
branded product I think yeah or hesitant
especially Millennials to bank with
Goldman Sachs yeah yeah it's interesting
we've seen like you know the challenges
of of banking and the issues that come
with maybe they could have circumvented
that just given their cash balance and
the things they have going on but
um do they want to like navigate the
public company you know challenges of
all of a sudden trading like a financial
services company on part of your
business
sell products yeah through your phone
yeah big one yeah
you own the data and then sell that data
sure from your phone I mean there's so
many ways that they could monetize
yeah
you should go pitch it I think I
mentioned this in an old Apple video
where I felt through potential when they
came up with the first credit card was
really to go really just dive head first
into banking yeah and issue loans and
just do everything under the sun just
for personally for the millennial yeah I
think they're companies these days are
kind of scared of you know expanding
their purview because of the ftc's
Mandate right now and like I forget yeah
we're talking about no just like just
how aggressive the FTC is about policing
um uh like Anti-Trust stuff in the US I
mean it's kind of crazy right like
they're stopping Facebook Google Amazon
Apple from doing like 20 million dollar
Acquisitions but then Tick Tock is just
operating with free reign in the U.S
right like that's wild to me that
they're focusing on these tiny deals
that these companies are doing rather
than policing you know a big issue
um so I think some of the companies are
just wary of that I mean Amazon
definitely is because I think Amazon
believes they will get broken up at some
point and split between their AWS
business and the retail business right
um but I think that like you know Apple
all of a sudden going into banking like
all these companies going into all these
different areas where they're
controlling more and more of your lives
you just congressmen are going to have a
field day with that being their viral
thing that they can talk about to try to
get on their new cycle it is interesting
though with with Amazon Basics they like
you go and buy batteries first two
results Amazon Basics cheaper than
anything else we have more reviews yeah
and better delivery yeah you can get it
today yeah
why would I get the one day delivery is
always insane to me that I could order
something in the morning and it's like
it'll arrive between 3 and 6 p.m today
yeah how I know it's amazing that's why
when people hate on Amazon I'm always
like come on yeah I just got like I
literally ordered this USB cable I
needed and it came two hours I'm curious
I think they should have food that would
be Amazon too don't think Amazon deliver
for food do they yeah
not groceries
yeah yeah exactly like imagine Amazon
for like you know you want you want like
a protein bowl down the street it's
there and then you go to Amazon Basics
beauty of those businesses it's like the
Standard Oil you know model from the
Rockefeller days the beauty of those
businesses when you're that big is that
you can be loss making in one area in
order to acquire market share because
you know you're generating profit
elsewhere yeah and like that's what
standard oil did so well is they would
just like completely drive out
competition in a new region by
undercutting the market and operating in
a loss because they knew they were
generating profits Three Counties over
or whatever the thing was so they didn't
care like they would you know bleed you
dry in your competition area because
they knew they could make it up
elsewhere like that's what antitrust
Regulators are terrified of with all of
this stuff it's like more standard oils
right building do you think that's a bad
thing necessarily because part of me
because it's pro-consumer I don't part
of me believes that one company can
lower costs overall because they have
such a big market share yeah or I mean
they could take the opposite approach or
just charge whatever they want because
they have such big markets yeah I mean
I'm a free market guy yeah in general
like I don't believe in a ton of
Regulation I don't believe in a ton of
intervention
um and I think the markets sort these
things out in general so
um I mean I'm personally a proponent of
just like allowing these things allowing
the market forces to work and allow it
to be governed that way I also generally
think like Amazon's intention from the
day it was founded was Pro customer and
everything was about lowering prices and
everything was about improving customer
experience and so like there's not a
data point I don't think really in the
Amazon story that says like they're
gonna all of a sudden just gouge
customers on prices because they own the
market I just don't think we've seen
that right they've gouged Brands they've
said like hey you produce a bunch of
these you know USB wires well we have
all the data and so we're going to
produce the same wires and sell them
cheaper than you and deliver them faster
but like the customer actually benefits
from that I'm getting cheaper and faster
and so that's pretty good
um and you know if you're a conversation
I think the distaste for that is that
they could do those at a loss just to
drive out the other person yeah which
yeah I kind of understand the other
anti-small business right
entrepreneurship right I'm actually a
little bit shocked that you said you
were uh like
a
open-market person but you think that
the government should step in and
intervene with Tick Tock what why do you
not view government stepping in and like
let's say telling Apple you have to take
this off your app store and and placing
restrictions on things like that why
what's the difference are you okay with
that yeah National Security I just like
I mean China is our number one adversary
um and
the idea that they have control over
something that controls the minds of a
hundred million Americans like one third
of our population is I think a mass I
think it's the biggest National Security
risk that we face today so if you're a
president would you just do away with
Tick Tock yeah banana immediately done
gone do you worry about what other
things they might use National Security
for to ban like the slippery slope yes
uh yeah I think there has to be a I I
mean I think there has to be
um checks and balances on these things
like I actually don't I don't think it
would be easy for the president to just
do that overnight but I think the
legislative branch would get behind it
um India banned Tick Tock and people you
know complained about it for a month and
people were really upset consumers of it
that loved it Etc and then everyone kind
of moved on and said you think people in
the United States would just move on
because I feel like United States
citizens specifically are so attached to
their freedoms but like the people that
are very Pro Freedom actually probably
don't it like probably are the ones that
would get behind this
you know like you know you'd be like
more of like a right-wing left-wing
thing and I think more like right-wing
people would probably get behind the
idea that China you know like they would
put a good PR campaign on it I'm sure
and say like look what China's been
doing in the North Korea videos and like
there's evidence of these things
happening and it's not you know
manufactured I don't have all the
details right like I don't know how
separated it is I have people that I
know that work at Tick Tock that say
that there's like communication between
the Chinese entity and the US entity so
I don't know like how much of a real
split there is because technically
there's a tick tock us that's a separate
entity who knows how split it actually
is I'm not involved so I have no idea if
there's investigation and there is
actually proof that there's influence
that comes from the Chinese I think it's
it's like Espionage I mean it's like
it's a way of infiltrating American
culture at a very very deep and organic
level that is scary to me so you're
president what else do you do
no I mean look I think that one of the
biggest issues facing the country is
um that smart ambitious young people do
not want to go uh into public service uh
I think that's probably the biggest
issue facing us over the next 50 100
years is that
um most of the people that end up in
Congress or
um you know in the higher uh in these
higher offices are people that want to
be like career politicians and they go
in and they're constantly just like
horse jockeying for power over a long
period of time because of lack of
terminal emits because of no campaign
Finance reform everything's a ton of
money you serve in the Congress and
you're like and then you leave and you
get your 15 million dollars exactly you
know uh deal and so what I think which I
think is an interesting proposal is you
have to pay way better for people in
Congress and there's a very strict term
limit like when you go and you get
elected you might you can make 20
million dollars in Congress Over a
four-year period really and the smartest
people in the world will all of a sudden
want to be in Congress and it's not just
going to be these like you know ego
driven guys that just want to go and
accumulate power over 40 years because
it's a short stint maybe say it's six
years say it's eight years but you're
gonna get paid a whole lot if you do
certain things so say say you
incentivize Congress you know who
brought this up to me Anthony scaramucci
uh the mooch the uh guy that worked for
Trump for like 10 days as communications
director say you said to all of Congress
um if you guys balance the budget at the
end of the Year everyone is going to
make 15 million dollars every single one
of you will make 15 million if you
balance the budget you produce a
balanced budget
um all of a sudden and you put a strict
terminal you said six years is the max
you can ever serve you'd have a whole
lot of really smart people wanting to
work across the aisle to get something
done yeah that's true at a broader level
because they would all be incentivized
to do it it's like incentives are
everything so why not create incentives
that drive the smartest people to want
to actually work government spending is
like if you don't spend it then it goes
to waste you know that's this mindset
where we have to spend it we get more
money than if we spend it because then
we need more yeah it's just a broken
system yeah I think I totally agree
that's why I think you need something
radical that completely changes the
whole idea of the career politician is
just broken to me like it was never
supposed to be that way it was supposed
to be you worked in industry and you
went and did your public service and
then you went back to Industry you did
your four years you did whatever it was
I was serving the public and we've now
morphed into this weird dystopian world
of these career politicians who go and
like accumulate power and wield their
influence over the course of 40 years I
mean I had a friend
um who was working for a congressman and
he went you know got elected and went to
kind of his first vote and they were you
know the people on his party were like
what are you going to vote on this and
he said well I'm gonna vote no and they
were like no you're going to vote Yes
and he said no I kind of ran on you know
a platform that would lead my
constituents to believe I'm gonna vote
no and they basically told him if you
don't vote Yes on this you're never
going to get bill passed in your entire
time in Congress
and so like what the hell right I mean
it's a guy that just ran that got
elected that's not allowed to vote on
the principles of what he ran on because
of the whole idea of career politicians
and because he knows that he actually
now has to vote Yes if he wants any
chance of accelerating and getting to be
more influential the exact same thing
you almost have to feed into that
because otherwise you're not going to
get any of your points across or any of
you you're not going to get the donors
and you're not going to get the money
it's like you have to elect it take a
few shortcuts here to get this one thing
that you want they eventually passed and
it's like you know everyone kind of does
each other favors yeah and it ends
justify the means it all becomes this
like Machiavellian game so I just think
the idea of creating a better set of
incentives and systems and severely
limiting terms
um is an interesting one and it would
prevent the revolving door thing right
like politicians wouldn't be just
waiting to get their cushy Consulting
gig where they like make connections do
you think that should be legal what
people to go get like their cushy
Consulting gig after serving that's kind
of a market thing right like their pay
because they have influence and they
have relationships still and so I like
is it legal I don't think stock trading
I think like stock trading should be
completely obliterated I think that's
crazy that politicians have been able to
do that but index funds would you stop
yeah no that's what I mean yeah
like sure go invest in Vanguard they
were trying to pass that just for
recently right yeah yeah I think after
the whole Nancy Pelosi thing they were
trying to say well yeah they shouldn't
trade individual stocks they should just
invest in a fund while they're you know
yeah I I completely agree with that
um I don't know I don't think you can
ban politicians from like leveraging
their relationships and Consulting gigs
like it would just be hard to police
like what level is it I don't know and
your market value is high because you do
have relationships and the network
really matters but I think it would all
get reduced if you had less of these
like career politicians there because
then my influence would kind of leave
with me like the people that I had
worked with would be gone after the four
years and so it would be like I don't
know am I still worth 50 million dollars
if I don't know any of the people that
are in Congress now by the way really
quick I want to let you know that's an
hour behind oh [__] yes oh so guys sorry
we have to end it so abruptly thank you
so much for coming on the podcast thank
you this has been incredible you're
clearly a very intelligent person so uh
yeah or I'm just too confident I don't
know one of the two this was a blast
though guys thank you I'm glad you gave
me the coffee at the beginning because
otherwise I wouldn't have made it you're
welcome and you do seem smart enough to
get a free stocks on Instagram link down
below and of course all of yourself will
be left down below as well thank you
guys so much for watching and until next
time please thank you